two
good afternoon everybody
yes off the rails May 10th okay
here we are
sponsored by the one the only
gamer sup Nation that's right suck me up
baby I'm sucked up
shut me off hmm
it's good welcome everybody today oh
okay
oh no
grandpa is feeling a little frisky today
helicopter
oh no so now that I'm up you're down uh
what was that uh quote again wow
[Music]
another Wednesday another Masterpiece by
the boys
uh you know it is Wednesday man it is
Wednesday fans Wednesday
I got a haircut
looking sharp I can't say that I'm crazy
about it to be honest you know what's
weird
it looks so dark because I had bleach
tips do you feel that way do you notice
that it looks so dark it does seem
darker than before yeah
the other thing is I'm not sure that the
short hair really
compliments me I don't know it's a Vibe
it's a Vibe I think you rock it I think
it's good I need to do something about
this I need to grow a neckbeard or
something dude I've been telling you man
take them out of hair bring back the
afro I want the afro back I'm not 23
please it's a Jew for okay I'm not
African-American well or African bring
it back that's what the afro is right
it'll be jufro bring back the juice
my mistake
jeez dude
I'm just kidding I think it's fine to
say afro I've always wondered that
though afro definition
afro it's a hairstyle worn predominantly
by black people in which naturally kinky
or tightly curled hair is styled in a
rounded shape
traditionally by black people
and sometimes Jewish people I like the
jufrobe phrase yeah yeah Rock the dufro
bring back the joof okay 2023. Jews okay
give me a couple months I like I like it
I set myself back the Chad is saying the
short hair way better so oh really that
seems to be the consensus I'm mostly
seeing so I I personally like having it
short from the perspective of just
living my life sure you know me too
yeah I get that Dan
okay but if you guys like it short then
uh then then God bless and thank you
guys
yeah yesterday I went to the doctor did
a little checkup which was the first
time in years that was fun actually and
I'll tell you man
I saw a new doctor for the first time 33
years old and I was so happy
he started screaming that to me and I
was like uh
and I was like well then why are you
here I'm here to see a family I'm
getting into surgery today no no no no
I said what am I doing here yeah I went
to the UCLA Medical Group
it's great it's awesome I was super
stoked I did a full blood panel I tested
every damn thing the only thing I didn't
test is testosterone because I have to
do that like when I first wake up
so I gotta go do that but
so y'all can stop uh diagnosing me with
every known uh illness we will know for
sure
in the next coming days but I will say
this
my blood pressure was great
well done would not expect that
I would not expect that why why would
you not because I'm fat and inactive
I guess those are decent reasons right
yeah yeah and I just I had just finished
chewing a nicotine gum too which I
thought was like oh brother
but it was good
so I'm you know it was good
um another so today we are planning
the long-awaited crew swap out
we will be playing musical chairs
including myself
we'll be doing it in uh phases where
we'll all rotate so when we start cam is
going to come in and host
flip and I'm gonna go in and do whatever
A B does uh it's all flipped get berated
by the host right thanks for saying it
what do I do over there AB
S I just sit here I'll take care of the
rest whenever I'm up there oh we won't
be switching at the same time damn it
say what now if I was sitting over there
I could beat you and I could explain
he's really hoping to be posting while
you were in his chair I'd be down for
that I I think it's I think I think you
deserve to have that
you can host next if you want to
fudge the order
I don't feel mess everything up well
I'll talk about in Discord we'll see
yeah so I'll be doing research I know
what ABR does
he does research he fact checks
during the live show I mean you do so
much baby you do so much
I know me too no I know it
the man does so much he bleeds he sweats
all for us
and I'm happy to say that you know for a
change your work has paid off and today
we are gonna have been a good show
hell yeah which is different than the
usual terrible shows that we have here
[Applause]
on the History Podcast all right
so anyway we have that to look forward
to thank you
yeah
actually we should [__] now that you got
me going on the good doctor I kind of
want to look at that
but we have a ton of segments and
everybody's gonna basically just have to
pick up the dog where I let the last
person left off
and uh and take it from there
there's a few things at the top of the
show One um Zach Lewis live
uh we have made something to commemorate
the great Zach Lewis live
on uh Jeff May 16th I believe 13th May
13th you will be gone right on Thursday
and Friday uh I'm going Friday I'll be
here tomorrow okay okay so and because
your friend is your Friday your show no
Friday I have a wedding to go to but oh
unrelated yes yeah yeah
and then your live shows on Monday it's
on Saturday Saturday
yeah so go ahead Zach or Sam sorry who
is Sam who's Sam here oh my God
celebratory music hit us with something
yeah you know oh my God Sam made this
thank you
well open it before you thank her
brother right it could be a Thursday
dinner oh God could be a Cosby doll
you know a cursed a bison skull it's a
box
is there a certain way I should open
this
uh I don't think it's fragile right Sam
just tear into it
what the [__] is this go ahead does it
smell okay oh my God no it's actually
sick it's not cursed
holy [__]
vintage Ed Hardy no I'm kidding [__] oh
holy [__] dude oh my God
show it off show the patchwork and
everything
so this is 100 Sam uh made
I did are you kidding oh my God whoa
the jacket is a vintage leather jacket I
did not sew the jacket but I did
everything else whoa what is the tiger
is that pink and then yeah and then you
also embroidered that
I sewed the patches on
damn that looks clean yeah thank you so
much holy sh oh my God the three-peat
the Roxy the Troubadour and the uh
this is like the nicest thing thank you
so much The Viper Room patch is coming
oh my goodness this is so [__] nice I
could cry well go ahead and cry yeah
this is this is just like cry coward
yeah literally because I dare you to cry
[__] cause there's this this Ed Hardy
jacket that we've talked about
holy [__] it is based off of a jacket
that Zach showed me like a year ago wow
and the Ed Hardy version of it is three
thousand dollars holy mother of Jesus
we probably do it this
thank you so much I hope you like it I
hope it [__] love this this is
absolutely amazing there it is I'm blown
away okay Dad thank you give it up for
Wham it's a lot cooler that you made it
Sam yeah thank you so like from bottom
line and then Sam is there any lore with
the leather jacket was it recovered from
a wreck or a graveyard a cadaver
actually owned by the lead singer of
Credence Clearwater again
oh my God yeah his initials are in the
breast under the in the inseam
but congratulations everybody's very
excited uh for a resident rock star
thank you so much everyone's demanding a
hug oh look at that yeah yeah let's see
it
and A Tear please
trust us it happened and A Tear uh if
you could force one Zach first
go ahead
they're beautiful I better see one tier
that's nice that is nice the Oscars are
not that is nice this is the coolest
[__] special I've ever gotten like
this is [__] amazing well good job
thank you so much thank you what can we
say family you know what I mean no
that's a big accomplishment it sure is
oh I love this well and I want to say
that this man he still has some tickets
left even though he makes it sound like
there's no tickets left if you want to
see this guy at Coachella this show has
to sell out right so that's the only
opportunity this man at Coachella less
than 25 tickets yeah it is one thank you
so much there's one ticket looks good
yeah Louis will be uh headlining the
Roxy the Coachella of uh the old
Coachella main stage that'd be I don't
know about main stage that is the goal
you're the exactly well said
but there you go congratulations thank
you thank you guys thank you so much so
happy and proud of our
of our boy thank you thank you very much
yeah you know
everyone hears is you guys are the best
what can I say thank you
you're welcome
where's my jacket
uh so we have a sandwich or a jacket Dan
we have uh yeah see this is the problem
Sam we didn't bring enough to share with
everybody I'll make everyone a Zach
Lewis yeah can we get our Troubadours
Zach Lewis live leather jacket made by
the cadaver of uh
of some clydence kleinwater uh uh uh
roadie
yes everyone wear them to the show
okay so let's see so that's exciting
well done I have to talk about what
happened yesterday on the see you next
Tuesday podcast which is what I got to
do for members
it was a total and utter disaster I
showed my phone number on the screen
twice one was Dan's fault twice was
Dan's fault
and by the way my number's already
changed so don't [__] try calling me
anymore don't text me don't call me
people were sending really nice messages
you know but I'm like
don't off but also don't when you
started answering
well you know I figured I had to answer
at least one but uh what happened let's
see
so
what happened was I this happens
occasionally because listen I'm not an
experienced streamer I don't know I'm
just I'm just there doing my thing
what do you expect I mean listen how
long have you been in the game I'm not a
streamer I'm a YouTuber it's different
it is different right baby I mean you
you know
[Music]
it's not that hard really yeah you need
I'll tell you what you need you need
what's up on your phone and a a
quarantined browser that you never use
that's Dan's job Dan should have said
that up for me nobody knows the depths
of my incompetence more than Dan I mean
that's your [__] job bro when we
initially set it up which was what like
almost a year ago right I I did
encourage you to use a dedicated browser
I don't even know what that means
I mean I was like yeah yeah I was like a
browser that you look porn up on uh to
do your show like Firefox specifically
for CNN yeah Firefox for for this yeah
but that wouldn't have actually even
helped no in this case that would have
helped many other things but not in this
case no yeah well the other thing wasn't
the other stuff wasn't that bad we just
need to turn off display capture you
need window cap that's it cab knows and
that's what I'm saying you understand
that that life okay
I almost docked Zach wants and I learned
my lesson no display capture oh for real
yeah this is a long time ago it happens
to the best of us
and that's my phone number on stream too
almost divine intervention yeah I was I
had my backpack streaming and I was love
was calling me I was like oh Love's
calling me I turned the phone around and
I show his number and I lost service for
a split second and it didn't show it oh
oh yeah
that's right yeah you know so
there it is you know if it happens to a
b who's like a pro streamer could happen
to anyone
mm-hmm not my fault
so anyway what happened was Dan sent me
a WhatsApp message and I opened what's
up on my screen on accident
which usually is isn't a problem I
didn't think I showed anything but Dan
when he tags me it shows my [__]
number instead of saying Ethan now why
is that that I don't have an answer for
uh
when people tag me it shows my name it
doesn't show let's still do that if you
tag me on the group like I just don't
get it I can test it right now I was
like hold up your phone to the camera so
we can all see yeah yeah of course my
food my new phone number yeah see I see
Dan and then cam just says Ethan
cam says Ethan yes just says Ethan okay
and then I do that uh Dan it just says
Ethan too so it might be a thing just in
the browser version but it was only
yours and again I'm joking that it's
your fault I don't know yeah for the
people at home who are like it's not
Dan's fault you're an idiot
well it is kind of but uh
well whose is it then it is my uh job to
anticipate as you put it the depths of
your incompetence exactly that's all I'm
saying that's all I'm saying yep I think
it's my fault for dropping the videos to
begin with of the
[Music]
yeah it was a horrible Twist of event I
tried to make the best of it so it
showed my phone number
and I was like oh my God you know I
realized that at first my I started I
got one call from an unknown number and
I was like oh [__]
well you probably because we all we were
all watching here at the studio right
whenever you're streaming we always have
it up so that we can and [__] raise our
blood pressure right and and so we all
saw that so I mean our our group chat
immediately blew up with all of us
screaming at you in all caps to take the
[__] off the screen right right yeah
and so uh the best part happens when
I'm like oh my God we ended the stream
erased it restarted
and then I won this was in my opinion
the dumbest thing
um here's a video I guess of it
so I I started the new stream
and then I took a gas giazzo giasmo
gyesso screenshot
to send this to Dan and I'm like why
does it show my number and then it
opened it on my [__] streaming screen
and I immediately docked my stuff again
did it again like the minute I started
the [__] stream
which was actually way worse because the
last one was just there for a split
second and then this one I just I just
surrendered it surrendered to the void
and at this point I think I had like um
[Music]
500 uh unread text messages and 300 on
after phone calls my phone was just on
mute it was just unusable
uh
yeah it was a wild ride because then I
had to call my Mobile provider because
you know
um
it's already happened to me once the Sim
swapping thing a long time ago
so I had to call them and make sure
everything was uh good
so that should be fine
but uh it's a [__] nightmare boy
changing your phone number is one of the
worst things in the world
it's just
it's just so bad yeah but my phone was
just blowing up non-stop so I said okay
[__] this I'm answering one of these
goddamn calls because I kept being like
don't call me don't text me I said okay
let's see okay what do you want
hey is this Ethan yeah this is Ethan so
what do you want
yeah
hey I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry I
can't even I love your show it's all
right bro it's all right
I love you guys too please don't call me
anymore
all right bye
yeah you know it's funny that
again it was all really nice it was all
like nice job on the weight loss King
you're looking good people were texting
me people were texting me good night
people some people text me good morning
I changed it this morning yeah I got
good morning texts I got lots of good
night texts special it was all really
nice you know but at the same time
you know
it's my phone number
but actually nobody can say this
when you look at our members uh services
perks nobody else can say this
we like to plug this here remember lives
BTS crew lore access to Discord yada
yada Ethan's phone number yep
so again going above and beyond wow
Nobody Does it like this every other
guest books no we're so candid with your
audience it's beautiful it is and you
know it is it's an open book good night
guys I wish I had a way this mass text
all my new besties good night everybody
you could do the
yeah might as well at this point it
could text everybody when you go live
oh I'm watching Everybody
yeah you can steal everyone's
information and sell it to China that's
most important
well it's not a community phone number
it's a real phone number you know so you
could just mass text enough
that's what I wonder I do Wonder but
anyway there's some great memes that
came out of it
[Laughter]
Ethan what the [__] are you doing get
what's up off the screen your phone
number's there Ethan no which is
basically what you can't keep getting
away with it I mean that I think that
word for word is what I said verbatim
yeah
Ethan when uh ELO and Ethan tells her he
showed number on stream which I did do
that
I had she had to come down and help me
because she had some information I
needed
yeah
this is I don't understand this meme it
says leaking the number leaking is
number restarting the stream and then
showing his number again immediately
after Ethan why would Dan do this I
don't understand that meme
I don't get the joke you don't know that
Meme format no I just don't get the joke
because it was your fault oh I see the
meme format's not applicable in this
case it's not your fault
yeah
Ethan after leaking his number Ethan
don't message me unless
you started taking content suggestions
too
actually I'll be honest someone sent me
a video that's in the document today
yeah it was really good so what can you
do I said [__] it I'm gonna open it you
know
didn't see any penises
nothing vile fantastic nothing even
unpleasant to be honest
um
the whole crew after Today's Show yeah
the whole the whole uh subreddit was
Ablaze so I'm just I guess here's all of
our live streams that were erased
so I'm sorry to all the members who
didn't get to see it but to be truth 80
of it was on mute me calling
to try to resolve some security
panicking yeah yeah
people are asking uh if we can re-upload
it censored um it was not recorded
locally uh by Ethan and like we said we
deleted the uh existing videos so um
it was just me sitting
right it really for the most part wasn't
that interesting but
yeah part of it was pretty [__] fun I
screen recorded when you told ELO though
it was kind of funny how like
desensitized she was yeah she didn't
yeah that's true actually here um is me
calling
to tell her I needed help
I need your help I just showed my phone
number on on screen I
don't know for like a long sustained
amount of time
nice
[Laughter]
oh brother here's a screenshot of our
WhatsApp in the moment yeah it took me a
minute stop showing what's up what the
[__] are you doing stop stop bro there's
images below your phone number was on
screen
uh
Tuesday it used to be our day to relax
yeah people getting high in there it's
our day off that's right folks
yeah you know me too actually this
membership whole Shenanigans is just
destroying our
our peaceful beautiful day but there it
is that's what five days a week means
Nobody Does it Like Us
nobody
um oh yeah I also leaked Twitter Twitter
DMS with uh
only fans which I knew people were going
to make a whole big [__] dumbass
thing about yeah that was really good
that you actually showed them because I
I saw all the dumb conspiracies uh
people being like what is this [__]
[__] I was messaging only fans because
somebody made
of fake only fans account for ELO
obviously fake
and people were passing it around
being like uh
again I don't care but it's weird to me
when there was people trying to present
it like it's a real thing and then
starting all this Discord about it
now I don't think there's anything wrong
with only fans it's just she's not doing
only fans
and I said yo you can you guys [__]
remove this what's wrong with you
and they go okay if you want us to
remove it you need Ela to send us a
photo of her holding her ID and a piece
of paper with the date and her face
visible I said what the [__] delete
I said [__] why don't you ask the
person that made the [__] account to
verify their information before I have
to come ask you to erase this [__]
I'm considering taking legal action in a
sense because they're so it's so [__]
up and I go yo you need to run this up
to management I'm not doing that
they said the supervisor reviewed your
request
and uh also compliance however it will
not be possible for us to confirm the
impersonator
unless we're provided with the person
holding a photo ID
and a piece of paper
with their face clearly visible with the
date but she's not your monkey to dance
you allowed somebody
to impersonate her on your [__]
website
and it's not like Twitter this is a
website where people post nude photos
they have to be 18 they have to have
some they have to verify their ID to
make an account right only fans I mean
what the [__] dude it's crazy right
how would they I mean I guess they just
faked it just faked in it photoshopped
and I a picture of an ID
you can probably change the display name
it's not your ID it says it's got a
picture of her I mean here you can pull
up the fake account let's see Ela Klein
only fans let's see what's the URL
there it is
oh it's gone right now go ahead and look
but uh maybe after yesterday after I
bitched about it they removed it
not available okay okay well at least
they took it down still y'all need to
[__] like really examine your policy
on that one that is stupid as hell
thank you
okay it's gone
mission accomplished I guess
um
Rich Lux a friend of the show
actually took this as an opportunity to
try to cancel Dan Rich Lux has been
after Dan for some time
and at least somebody's backing me up
that it wasn't my fault yeah shout out
you know
nice to have at least somebody in my
corner Rich Lux uh unfortunately it's
Rich Lux
another reason Dan from H3 needs to be
fired not to mention he blocked me after
I donated 100 in chat I vaguely remember
that what happened
I think it was during the ace Fest
Fallout right we were talking about how
he got kicked out of the event and I
think that he wanted to talk about it
but when um it was sent in chat Dan set
he said it on the show when it happened
he was like I just
I just banned him I Remember You Banned
him but I don't remember why
he was trying to cancel Dan for some
[__] [__] oh he was saying
homophobic for some total [__] yeah
because of some inflection you did on
your voice remember
that's where all this beef originated
wait yeah maybe it didn't have anything
to do with acefest actually it's that
I'm a raging hobo phobophone no really
yeah yeah he'd been coming for damn for
a while
uh so Dan uh abandoned thanks for the
money idiot
last summer I guess he hasn't forgotten
eh
Dan ruined the show for me uh what are
we gonna do without Rich Lux
listen Rich if I got a pick between you
and Dan you know I got us
I gotta stand with my boy even though
you got my back
I'd picked Dan 95 times out of 10.
depending on
the tea of the week right if I pissed
you off that week or something five
percent means everything I pick you 100
of the time 100 at 100. he says can't
wait till he leaves I'll be throwing a
party bro you're you should be
embarrassed to say that it's not that
serious
with the moon bounce and pizza and at
Trisha Paytas impersonator
yeah so I was just kidding that will
there be balloon animals too
maybe we'll flower that squirts water
he does dress like a clown
oh no I mean literally I'm not like
like you mean because like what do you
mean by that
like he like where's the double makeup
all the time doesn't he well he probably
wouldn't put it that way but clown
comedian but I think clown I don't know
but Dan is uh clown I mean you're you
could say whatever you want about the
guy
but yeah I was just kidding Rich about
it being Dan's fault
so the comments were all pro Dan
I stopped watching them a while ago what
happened now um well lania Lumpkin huh
Dan is literally the only reason the
show is alive okay hold on Lauren
more replies do I dare love Dan have I
missed something
you need to dance contribution season 6
are undeniable oh here we go he has a
critical role in keeping Ethan on track
and helping him avoid significant
controversy dude it's yeah I appreciate
I mean I appreciate your sporting damn
but it's really just not that serious
[Laughter]
so shout out to our Luxy boy
and Dan says you have clown makeup rich
which to be fair
what would you describe that as
I was gonna say to be fair I do see
where you're coming from
I wouldn't describe it like that I mean
he's talking about throwing a party with
a bouncy castle and balloon animals and
[__] I mean
I think we might seltzer water out of
the flower yeah exactly just y'all's
makeup it looks awesome it's yours yes
Yaz the Clown
it's serving makeup
serving what animal balloons
sorry
I'm just backing up Dan I gotta do it
okay to be honest I liked Rich looks and
then he went rogue or something I don't
I remember what happened I was uh oh
yeah I was a fan ferment and I was like
uh
what was his thing he used to say uh
he's got the saying that he always says
and I tweeted at him once
what was it
whatever
shout out rich
the house yeah the house girl
boots down the house yeah but Shadow's
saying reach Lux
reach Lux yeah
well there it is uh congratulations to
Rich Lux I'll see okay now now I don't
know what you call this
but I will say if you can just add a
clown nose
and it does that much work
then you might have a point
right is that all you changed cam is the
clown knows that's it holy smokes
welcome to a new episode of the cloud
s yeah I got kind of friendly with all
these Goss channels and then I realized
that they are just kind of all the worst
and then I was like I better dismiss
myself I'm the dip yeah
but okay the house uh the CL you know do
your thing girl
let's go appreciate that Dono though oh
yeah so much for your support
well he can watch he just can't chat
yeah
he just has to shut the [__] up
like you can watch right now no problem
open invitation anytime
I mean chatting is a privilege
people saying I'm fine as [__] I one
person said that
let's amplify that
one person said that people saying I'm
fine everybody's saying I'm fine as [__]
just one person
I still got a lot of I got a lot of
movement to do but I'll tell you I
haven't fit into this shirt in a long
time
yeah it's happening the weight loss is
happening guys
[Applause]
it's happening thank you
so that was kind of just a fun whole
adventure and uh one more thing and then
we'll start our musical chairs
Danny Gonzalez shout out to a friend of
the show Danny Gonzalez
he was a guest a while ago I'm a fan
he's a great guy sweet guy good content
creator
wearing that Godzilla dress
I would love to see it King
love it
so thank you Danny we love you we'll
send them some stuff we should reach out
for sure
okay so with all that being said we do
have a full show to do
but at this point we are going to be
switching roles which means
uh
do you want the opportunity to trash Me
Maybe or sure so you want to do like me
and you switch and we'll do and then how
is that gonna work
if me and you everybody switches
and then me and a b switch
and then
we'll figure it out
you want to do that we had a whole plan
but unless you want to do it that way I
mean you know you could switch and then
we could continue the rotation I think
we can figure it out all right
everybody's got their little Brands all
right let's see let's see let's see what
you got
everybody rotate okay where should I go
all right Kim you go to uh that's what
I'm saying none of this man yeah this
[__] everything up so oh wait so hold
on now cam doesn't know where to go
nobody knows where to go should we just
do like we planned I think so okay sorry
so that means cam comes here and then
you go yes indeed we can at the end we
can just uh swap it yeah we can play
around later
if you like
all right yeah no you're coming here
Olivia I'm going to Zach so Kim you go
to Ethan's seat
and so to talk
they can't hear you you
oh [__]
okay they can oh hey I can hear myself
yo you got a little fan back here it's
kind of a Vibe so let's see you don't
have a mute switch I'm guessing right
this is an open mic at all times okay
well I can't host so I'm gonna shut up
now this is working okay because
everybody sees it real quick producer
Olivia's stunting over there in the
Scorpio I look good in this chair all
right I'm muting my mic uh is everybody
ready
I got chat GPT open cam I'm gonna
[__] check every damn day hold on let
me do it my first move is Ethan
this is me
Mr
gave a little thing is yeah
cam I'm so sorry to interrupt but it's
time to go to break okay listen to the
ad read real quick are we actually doing
the ad read right now uh is it is it
okay I'm gonna be doing my mic we're
doing it okay hold on wait so wait wait
I don't want to [__] up the ad read this
is this is intense uh do I just you got
it you got it uh do I open up the
yeah just click the top of the dock
there it's a URL to that gamer Subs ad
yeah okay and then I just read off
whatever just read it there's some
instructions you just kind of follow it
do your thing
all right hey everybody today's episode
is brought to you by gamer Subs that's
right we love gamer subs don't we folks
I'm sipping on uh
[Applause]
I don't know what flavor did you get
today Ethan a b black cherry black
cherry I'm slipping on black cherry it's
my most favorite flavor uh some cool
stuff about gamer Subs is there's no
sugar in this bad boy can you believe
that wow is that amazing is anybody else
back there drinking some gamer Subs hell
yeah bro I'm skipping the mango metal
right now dude the mango meta that's a
beautiful flavor I love that one uh
thank you love
um
gamer Subs now has a mobile ad and drops
all drops will be accessible 20 minutes
early through the app moving forward can
you believe that that's incredible stuff
wow uh I've never done an ad read before
it tastes great that's [__] right you
got that goddamn right I love gamer Subs
it's beautiful it doesn't have lead like
competitors do I'm not gonna name them
um
it won't break a fast or take you out of
ketosis if you're into a keto diet
um I don't is there anything else to do
here I I kind of just blank out when the
ad reads are going on you're doing great
I'm doing great we all love gamer Subs
we all love games ourselves thank you
very much
um so sorry to break in here yep uh I
fact check does g fuel have lead I
didn't want to say the Confederate name
uh it's a brand Energy drink mix that
has been subject to controversy presence
of lead in the product so yes it does
according to Jet GPT wow
thank you very much all right
so if you're interested in gamer Subs
after that beautiful uh
improved ad read I just gave I'm very
nervous because this is a big deal doing
great yeah you're doing awesome bro
drive it home drive it home I love you
guys out there watching an H3 land and
if you love me and you love gamer Subs
go to gamersups.gg
Y and use three to get 10 off your first
one today
[Applause]
10 that's two times as much five percent
it's everything times two it's beautiful
all right let's get to the show
um
all right that was fun wow
wow okay
thank you so
I don't know let's look at the top of
show dog here actually actually there's
something that caught my my eye on the
uh dog I really like this uh Alex Jones
wants comedian arrested over prank call
now Alex Jones as you guys know he's a
dumbass he's an idiot he's a blowhard
he's a conspiracy theorist right-wing
grifter piece of [__] uh he received a
phone call from none other than Tucker
Carlson last week but the thing is uh it
wasn't tucks that tucks the I don't even
want to say that nickname it wasn't
Tucker it was uh
a piece of [__]
um
no Tucker's piece of [__] but it was a
Prank Caller using Tucker Carlson AI
let's give it a listen how do I uh
now how do I do this okay do I just drag
it over to this screen okay I'm trying
to make it not say gamer Subs but I
don't know how
she would have figured it out eventually
but now it's gone it's fine well we do
love gamer Subs uh how's my Ethan hat
etiquette doing right now is this no
heavy metals in it great cam great cool
um so I'm gonna play this video now
um
oh Sam's figuring out how to switch the
PIP real quick
hold on you can play while she finds it
all right I'll keep it playing it's
really about the audio anyways
hey there we go okay hey brother how you
doing hey Alex it's Tucker do you have a
minute to talk
absolutely
right out the gate you know he's a
dumbass he picks up he thinks it's on
face value it's Tucker
idiot you busy right now Dumbass Dumbass
idiot
you busy right now or you got a second
to talk
no no I just talked to meet with my wife
go ahead
I was thinking we could do a show
together where we're topless and we suck
each other's nipples and sort of play
with them a bit it would be a comment on
gender sort of a funny parody
interesting to know that Alex is down
right out the gate he I think he's
accustomed to sucking nipples with his
shirt off right out the top thing
what the [__] man
cam does a great Alex Jones
impersonation by the way did my number
yeah I do I could have called Alex as
Alex for not come up
you want to show the people what's going
on
hey what's up it's me hey you wanna
let's let's uh hold on what did he say I
think we could do a show together where
we're topless and suck each other's
nipples and sort of play with them a bit
sucking a ding dong thank you
I I have an update I have a fact check
update oh give me a fact so I asked
chachibi uh chat gbt
it's okay sitting in that chair
sometimes makes people stutter hmm
go on go on um I asked do you see uh
so do you believe that the YouTuber Rich
Lux dresses like a clown
do you guys want what is this relevant
or this doesn't seem relevant at all
right but but they did say that rich Lux
often incorporates bright colors bold
prints
and then it says well I don't know
though and I asked it well do you see
similarities between how rich Lux
dresses and how a clown dress is and
then chat gbt said well Rich lux's style
can be described as bold and colorful
there are similarities between certain
aspects of his at outfits and the
traditional clown costume
and it goes on into detail but I think
just to back up Dan uh with facts and
logic there we have a positive
confirmation there it's not funny
love that thank you very much
thank you
cool I don't know what you would do in
this situation but I appreciate your
input a b you're a valued member of this
team and you're the best at research uh
head and Olivia you're amazing at
research too I'm the captain right now
and I'm giving everybody a morale boost
thank you very much for all your
beautiful work oh what's this cam grants
just uh gave me a meme yeah I just uh
dropped a meme on the Discord let me
just pull that over this is true this is
this is some true stuff right here thank
you
all right let's keep it going with this
prank call now was this prank call
uh
uh did we exp so this is a guy who prank
calls others
politicians and then he uses AI to model
their voices and
that's what's going on here uh I haven't
watched him in a bit he does a lot of
like calling pranks to right-wing
grifters and you know just online
personalities like Alex Jones and other
no-name pieces of [__] but I think he's
recently Incorporated AI into these gags
and then Alex fell for it at first and
then well we'll keep going it became
obvious that I was just using sound
bites Bobby Tai what the [__] man
I know it's it's not good
well if this I mean it does sound like
he would say I'm so good now you don't
usually talk like that so he caught on
that it was an AI and he said oh they
are so good that it uh it sounds like it
you know I was I had high hopes for this
call when I heard about it
and uh I gotta say I'm a lit I feel like
he could have done better with this one
fine you know I think so too but wasted
opportunity it feels like very like
early 2000s uh using Arnold
Schwarzenegger sound boards the prank
call people but I mean Alex still fell
for it at first but I think what's most
interesting about this
is the fact that after the fact
um
Alex called back and was threatening
legal action against him let's let's see
let's hear that out uh yes
are you there uh uh am I on the air
no you're not on the air I'm on a break
so Alex called him on the middle of his
show on a break to tear his ass a new
one but it didn't go that way you got to
tell me you got to tell me if I'm on the
air right you know that right
yeah what's up what can I do for you my
man
well I mean I mean I can tell you
Tucker's getting his lawyers involved
and stuff I saw her tweets concerned
about it oh you should come on the air
and explain it all is that it's a prank
and uh and then you're worried about
Xander say hi and we have a friendly
interview I mean and and I think that uh
because we don't hear Tucker's getting
his lawyers involved but what exactly
have I done
well so apparently Tucker called or he
tipped it off to Tucker that uh
he is being impersonated and Tucker
wanted to pursue legal action I guess
should I do a call about it should we do
a poll yeah is what he did illegal to
prank call that's the poll yeah is that
a good poll I don't know sounds kind of
like well hold on what are we lawyers
let's not set me up to fail everybody's
gonna say that poll what's the what are
we doing a poll about I just think that
we need one yo Alex chill what the [__]
I think it's a good ball wait who's
doing that who's in The Sound driver
seat he's Dan oh it's [__] Dan
I'm so nervous right now guys it's time
you're doing great cam you're doing
great you're doing so well how about a
poll about Camas host how am I doing as
a host and yeah at the same time you
know what I I'm sorry to interrupt but I
wanted I do want to say yeah hold on
hold on hold on this is important I do
want to say that I believe that Michael
Jackson did nothing wrong okay hold on
you want to delve into that AB all right
Paul just went up yeah thank you Dan
yeah I mean I'm happy to talk about my
Michael Jackson what do you want to know
uh um no this is a bad poll Dan this is
a bad horrible poem we have an
overwhelming yes though I know it says
cam is doing so well yes also
everybody said yes well thank you guys
all right try to try to drive it home
here on the Alex Jones okay yeah hold on
let's keep it going
representing yourself somebody
but I sent you a text
mainly afterwards clarifying that it was
me doing an AI and you you I can help
you out right on this if you need help
yeah I need I need the team okay so
being the sleigh queen that I am I
looked into this and uh yeah this
gentleman goes by prank Stallone on
Twitter and as fake AB mentioned uh he's
going after right wing people all the
time or no cam you mentioned that sir
um he's gonna have to right wing people
all the time and uh Alex was pissed
about this and called out this gentleman
on his show it's linked right here 8A if
you want to open that oh hold on Olivia
is a fashion icon slay Queen oh thank
you yeah I didn't read this right up
afterwards let me
turns to load something turn
hold on let me go drag this over I'm not
used to this for oh [__] I don't wanna
[__] [__]
away coming perfect
oh [__] responded oh God
all right just take your time
Center yourself it's okay no you got
your character spot on right now wait
yeah nothing is
no nothing's [__] okay no nothing's
[__] yeah you're good okay hold on
here we go
I think By Design you can't leak
anything bad okay I just that was my
fear lawyers are involved in what you
did we believe let me tell the little
prankster uh pranks to loan something
turn across his lawyers are involved in
what you did we believe is a crime so I
think even though you think you're safe
a mechanic you're gonna get arrested for
what no he's not such a dumbass you
[__] idiot the idea they're talking
about he's actually going to get
arrested like you could you could
threaten like oh we're gonna sue you for
civilly because you impersonated I don't
know if that's that even seems really
thin I don't think that I bet he's got
some big old giant [__] tits but to say
they're gonna arrest him it's just
stupid if they [__] Canada they're
gonna get through your goddamn parade
for harassing some dumbass American
commentator you [__] idiot Alex Jones
you dumbass you're a demon you're a
[__] demon stupid ass dumbass
chair and and give me your best
take off when they don't let you move
back oh and dance and then you're like
over vertical yeah it's it's a weird
seating arrangement okay I feel like he
has uh turbulence in there too even like
an airplane
or attack us more you mess with the
wrong people son pre-cloud free Cloud
for this guy it's a good friend yeah
that's a good shout out you messed with
the wrong people Punk no he didn't
ups are off guys
I consulted with um chat GTP on this
decline
it says it is possible to be arrested
for using voice AI as someone to make a
prank call even if the prank seems
innocent depending on the circumstance
and the laws of your jurisdiction using
a voice AI to impersonate someone else
could be considered a form of identity
theft or fraud
uh do we know where he lives we can get
more specific
hold on I got it in Canada
yeah I said in Canada okay well hold on
I got a meme real quick to look at yeah
I uh dropped this this oh [__] actually
I got bad news for a boy it says in
Canada is considered front to use a
voice a item impersonate someone oh is
it no it says in order to deceive or
defraud others hmm
I like this bunny
that's my input on this meme great work
cam
thank you is that your camera impression
they're cool thank you thank you in fact
I'm gonna I'm gonna I'm gonna follow
criminal complaint you dumbass
she's such a baby
yeah like aren't you aren't you the guy
that harassed the parents of slain
children and you're throwing a [__] fit
about this it was like less than 30
seconds of a prank call saying he's
gonna pinch his nipples or whatever get
over it dude [__] grow up [__] tits
take your shirt off dumbass he is
nothing you're a demon bro you're a
demon he's like he's like a hot he's
like a red uh wait a minute did you just
say he's hot no oh
he's like a red uh Jelly Bean hold on
you ever see Alex Jones as a bodybuilder
yeah yeah he lost it all because he's a
dumbass dude
isn't his net worth like minus a billion
now he used to be hot but he's lost it
all
for being a dumbass he turned into a
human hot tamale yeah
this is your brain on grift people
there's your body with their daughters
and sons but it's the same crap you
don't get to steal our phone numbers and
poses us and then in our voices say
things we never said yes you do we need
to punish these people I want people to
know me for things I really said like
that the parents of Celine children at
Sandy Hook are liars and demons
he arrested now
at the CJs on Twitter
in fact let's show his original tweet if
we can
so he starts saying sexually explicit
thing what kind of Boomer prints out
tweets
I can't get over the Alex Jones that he
prints he does he's done this before he
prints out
things that you would look at on a
computer screen and does his show like
that I find it so bizarre and very very
wasteful for sure yeah he ain't
recycling he doesn't believe in that
thanks I want to close the show with you
and this isn't even [__] legible too
like you have to really tilt your head
and squint your eyes to read this I want
to you know do sexual things to you I
said this is a tiger Carlson instantly
my brain says this is AI and somebody
who spoofed his phone number calling me
doing it it was not instant you you were
ready to take your shirt off and play
with his nipples bro don't you lie don't
you lie Alex all right are we done can I
not be Ethan anymore funny oh you want
to finish it are you done with the bit I
don't know I'm very nervous in the hot
seat
well they call it the hot seat yeah it
is very hot up here can we get the can
we get the AC going yeah you're doing
good you're slaying thank you very much
Olivia I should be supporting you more
thank you very much beautiful your
tattoos are sick
all right
um what else what else on here
yeah pretty much we can work that out
all right cool thank you very much
there's Cameron
it's a baby [__] ass Alex Jones
all right Zach has taken over switching
Olivia you come over here you're gonna
be the sound bites now then Olivia is
actually in oh this is open
okay
so slay Ian
let's play in more like it Darth Slater
welcome into the table everybody welcome
[Applause]
you're doing great sweetie
I got it hi girlie I'm Sam now
girls yes love you okay yes hi girl how
do you talk with this delay we're in
love
can I see an eye can I see Zach
show me Zach
[Laughter]
well while you're so close
I don't want to see Zach anymore okay
well hold on if we're in character then
you would never switch to yourselves
Zach just for the record right yeah yeah
and we need the sound bites of Zach's
voice uh well uh where's Olivia Olivia I
gotta say how do you [__] talk with
this delay dude
wait oh you wear headphones and then you
hear it yeah in live and you talk while
oh yeah but I don't want to hear the
switcher that much yeah yeah yeah so go
back to leading in the show girl girl
you're doing great thank you wait okay
I'm gonna do a goof
I'm gonna do a goofing again
okay Olivia would never
sorry you're doing great sweetie
Shredder can someone check on Shredder
take him for a walk
Ethan can you take him for a walk
okay we have a this is yes yeah I guess
DJ Khaled friend of the show kind of
learning about breakfast
there he is
DJ Khaled everyone everyone knows DJ
Khaled
everybody let's see him on screen if we
could
they're beautiful all right here's DJ
Cloud learning about a balanced meal
it's called what that's just
it's called what
another word
yeah what is that perhaps what is that
what is this hey morning Sunday brunch
Sunday breakfast
wow
wow YouTube
[Music]
DJ Khaled
yeah should I say it oh God
the button works right type it out and
Discord say it the button
foreign
[Music]
why'd you push it
you didn't even say anything what'd you
say I just I'm it's better to be safe
than sorry [__] to me better that I
just
I could literally say anti-semitic [__]
and they can't drive are any of you guys
hungry
yes yes burritos
burritos sandwiches
oh God do I sound that way boba
[Music]
Boba could be real nice
sandwiches sound that's you Dan I
believe you're stamps You Gotta Buy you
gotta order okay everybody send me your
order
was that Sam's is that what I sound like
to you
okay everyone yeah send their send their
orders into in Discord
that's real that's nice
um Can someone look up how tall DJ
Khaled is
I've already looked it up and he's five
six five six just the right height no
bucket is recorded that explains a lot
come Olivia you're good at this thank
you so much
five seven well I'm Dan and I don't make
mistakes
also I guessed
as fast as Dan so I just said a number
shout out to uh Dan
chat gbt says that DJ Cal is
approximately five foot six inches
and um I also took the liberty of
looking into DJ khaled's net worth okay
good good it is approximately 75 million
dollars five million according to chat
he is the best girl
[Music]
I got you girl
slay more like slay Jay Khaled
no slay Queen yeah okay uh moving on
um can I see his hair can someone send
me a picture of his hairline I was
bullied because I had uh pretty good
actually I just need to see it just to
confirm I got it you want one of it like
painted on kind of thing I was bullied
love Center thank you love love God okay
chill love I'm trying to do my job here
there we go okay are we saying the same
thing okay
there's some information to be gained
from this I guess
if it could go on screen
anytime
you got it he got there
he got it okay wow thank you Dan that's
hair
that's some hair not a bad hairline to
be honest with you that's pretty good
girl that is not a bad hairline
my hair back people it could be worse
okay well so there it is DJ Khaled oh
wait oh I'm sorry I I I did make a
mistake here
let me play this video again this is
called what okay
so here he is talking about let me go
back
okay
go ahead this is called
hold on
you're doing great wait I'm that only
happens on Tick Tock bro come on this
isn't the roast Ethan show come on okay
okay
oh okay
it was so loud oh no I'm so sorry
there we go all right now now's the part
where you say something super funny
about the video like Ethan would do
I'll mess with the speed a bit let's go
fast let's go slow
oh that's good
and then I'll accidentally skip forward
let's get back well there he is he's
eating breakfast I mean that's it
[Applause]
do we rotate are we good we feeling good
you're doing great sweetie
do we have any memes
we have any DJ cows exporting it's
exporting okay
do we have any uh like elevator music to
play
um
nope wait we're cooking
have I engaged I've engaged everyone
think
okay Olivia's cooking hold on I'm
looking for he's cooking
hey why don't you pull up the before and
after we can examine I see her wait
you know let me play the audio from the
podcast I'm not a streamer oh my God I'm
hearing myself
oh right maybe I mean you know
oh
we got a meme from cam
[Laughter]
wow nice I like this man has got
breakfast on his mind it's all happening
he's cracked an egg on his hairline I
love the size box on the sausage here
so I just took a screenshot I didn't
realize the transform boxes no I think
it adds it's very avant-garde it's he's
on the The Breakfast Club I thought it
fit wow he's looking like a snack
beautiful work great work okay good job
team good in the words of Zuck
nice job team
all right rotate rotate oh I have a so I
just want to give us some Goss talk so
khalid's wife Nicole tuck
she is um
she was involved in some really juicy
Goths with um
Jeffree Star
wait tell me more
[Music]
wait actually I hate drama I hate it
don't tell me anything about it
wow that could be good we should do a
PowerPoint about that that's good
okay great thank you for the Goss
she got out like you want it more I can
tell you more I'm I'm rotating you could
keep telling me okay I'm rotating all
right thank you all right just it's been
great it's been absolutely lovely I love
it you go to the Scorpion chair
[Music]
good
thank you
they're on the computer
uh this is the Game of Thrones your
chair there's all these sharp edges and
[__] it's straight up sitting on the
yeah it's the iron the Iron Throne iron
throne
this is [__] how do I get to the
computer I know who's back there
talk about blocker so what do I do here
actually exactly oh I see
it seems like no okay okay
they haven't a couple people
chat you know what I'm I'm [__]
Banning these people chat chill the [__]
out
you gotta type in shot too you know what
I'm Banning these people oh I'm typing
chat
Sam station smells so good this place
has been marked and violated forever
it's my little candle I see it it does
look I think it's very Zen back there
personally how do I ban people I don't
even know how to do that really Ethan oh
Jesus that was quick thanks Ethan
okay you guys uh there is a wild suit
guy from Tick Tock AKA The Tick Tock
Taylor
let's do a little Deep dive please
okay apparently he says wild [__] to his
alleged clients why are they allege yo
you're in trouble like we don't know if
they're his clients
maybe because yeah why maybe maybe
because oh look into it I think it's
because
um
we can't tell if it's schtick or if
they're his real clients to them why are
you so cute when you talk [__]
here's a sample of his feed
hey chat chill the [__] out dude just
wait be shot just so annoying because he
impregnated his wife look at this pasty
English boy incredible night I had with
sir Les Ferdinand action I'm with your
favorite
I have a very Sleazy and oily Mexican
here Asian girl
okay do you a little bit of Pakistani
takeaway what the [__] cannot get it up
for this guy
too fat too old
I'm two Chinese girls at the same time
you're going to eat this little Chinese
boy
[Laughter]
it is wild I've seen that man like
roping them I don't know if you swatched
his longer form but like straight up
roping uh spanking
amazing
that's like so anti-protocol I feel like
he needs to uh
fit Jimmy Lee yeah
love to see that collab okay it was from
yesterday baby Bella you just got banned
for a week
what you do she just keeps spamming like
move on it's just so [__] annoying
like God we'll move on where we want
Trump has no need to ban all right this
is from yesterday Canadian Chinese boy
has dropped by for some molestation one
single buttoni button Peak lapel with my
accent color in the buttonhole check out
the peak of my pocket square undersized
flat Pockets that are fully lined
the accent color down here as well on my
fully functional cup I have him gift
wrapped in my 4D fit check out the tiny
little pop vent across the butt and we
will look at his ass let me open this
young boy up sure
[Music]
disgusting bro oh I hate it on the back
of the waistcoat I love this the suit is
fire though I've seen this before my
signature waistcoat we are absolutely
twinning and never leave it the moment
that he flew down from Canada four he
wanted to come here and show you his ass
Canadian Chinese there is no goddamn
reason a tailor needs to do that to you
I do I have heard that tailors are quite
handy they have a reputation for me do
they need to do this though the suit
does look good is it by practice your
choice
I mean it does look good but like guys
perhaps a little over the top maybe you
should Taylor's birthday soon
maybe he wants to Tampa
oh oh hell no what was that I could or I
guess Sam you're supposed to be like
what oh what was that yeah was that AB
who the [__] is a BB don't worry about
it
oh let's see if he's getting roasted I'm
not even in the damn
Pilot chair
okay
listen
anyone who's saying move on is going to
get banned I'm just telling you right
now chill the [__] out chat you guys are
so annoying who the [__] is saying move
on I just banned a Haley Bieber stand in
the chat nobody's telling you nobody's
saying move on
I don't want you to feel self-conscious
everybody loves you who is saying move
on I'm personally offended
no uh I'm I'm trying to find uh oh [__]
you guys I'm messing things up no you're
doing great
except for this now on the uh on the
computer
I'm just trying to to go to Discord okay
uh
a b said the profession of tailoring
dates back to the Early Middle Ages in
European towns where linen armors would
skillfully fit men with padded linen
undergarments used to protect the
interior of chainmail and plated armor
during that time men's clothing
consisted of tunics and hosiery
little factoid it is tailored very
interesting stupid tailors morons it is
I'm going to lick this sexy Italian boy
I have him gift wrapped look at this
there's no shot this guy isn't a
predator
my narrow semi-notch lapel with dot dot
dot dot hand needle and thread pick
stitching a Buckhead of breast pocket he
is Italian by the way with the Curve and
kick the peak of my pocket square did I
say gift wrap oh my goodness signature
details everywhere pick stitch Pockets
fully lined Pockets overlapping buttons
on the cuff functional cuffs you want to
see clean
this is clean this is what you call gift
wrapped in my 4D fit not a wrinkle
sometimes keemstar things aren't that
[__] deep at this
oh
baby look at it I could almost smack it
young Italian boy are you happy
[Music]
I set up a poll if anyone wants to share
their thoughts is the tailor a predator
yes or no uh
stop saying bad boy I don't understand
what could possibly be better about this
bowl
uh thank you for the Dono 50 Dono from
Carly
this is for my boy AB The People's King
thank you
um Rich Lux is a [__] idiot
we have a meme
hold on
I'm struggling with
if I I have I do have a question if I oh
never mind I figured it out
[__] yourself you good meme
I can't see it yet is it up oh okay suit
up you're a good meme
I like the uh I like the transform box
around the uh yeah it's very good
suit up
okay very slow that's that's the end of
that section keep going girl you're
doing great talk about it or maybe watch
more of his videos because they're all
good about the allegations okay now do
you guys think this is like a PNP type
of situation where they come there and
he just like jumps on them with the
camera
okay hold on hold on
uh uh a b send me more of his videos
who's doing this
okay Beau Black's chill
let me talk god damn it everybody knew
everybody
500. hey chill you guys this isn't the
Beau blacks podcast
maybe are you sending me more of his
videos uh yeah I'm working I'm working
on it hold on okay great dead air oh
[__] me
yeah
um
that's a good question though what you
ask is it a PMP situation where he just
blitzes them or is this a pre- uh
determined bit that makes a big
difference I feel like maybe he says oh
I'm going I'm I'm gonna I'm gonna do
this it's kind of kind of weird that's
just for tick tock I feel like he maybe
warns them before I I find it hard to
believe if he's just like groping them
because if he's touching their ass and
[__] it's weird
well I agree and if he's only like hey
I'm just gonna film this for tick tock
it's silly it's still not enough yeah
yeah yeah you'll be like I'm gift
wrapping this level like for for a
[__] for the priest why did he say
I'm about to lick this Italian man like
why would you say that yeah there's no
good there's no good reason I don't even
know like even if he's saying lick is
like
nah lick means to lick like hit a lick
like the one that got me was when he
said I'm opening up this little boy I
said no
I don't yeah like that doesn't even I
can't even think of like an alternate uh
meaning
[Music]
I was sent a video here let's see okay
hold on listen of all the custom and
made to measure suit companies out there
into Chino is one of the more popular
ones and it's also one of the companies
that you guys have asked me over and
over again to weigh in is this his
company
so that's what we're going to be doing
today I do want to say yeah
hold on this is the wrong way will not
do a sponsored review however that's a
big game partnership with indochino that
was for Instagram a few months ago as a
part of that partnership I did go
through the whole process and the suit
was given why can't I do that I sent a
real one more than gay
got it okay guys
one second everybody who's coming down
hard on a B for sending the wrong link
needs to shut the [__] up we're all
doing our best and I'm Banning people
right now you understand that thank you
Dan
anyone else who's saying a b
needs to be fired or whatever
um
he is Sam's Taylor
no no okay there we go
that's right
this is Roshan melwani that is Sam's
Taylor
hello he's made me a lovely suit it's
lovely it fits that's enough about my
suit what about his suit he's taller
than a Lamppost so you have to have the
long fit he's got the marzoni buttons
did he make that shirt I made this shirt
that's lovely lovely little accessories
yeah wide and
angled Pockets how did you become gang
marzoni buttons what do we call these
again Gauntlet cups I don't know you're
gay okay
oh and look he's sailing out to sea like
a pirate with his lovely turning round
there we are
with this lovely waistcoat and look at
his backside I'm not going to touch it
but whack
ah lovely are you happy with your [__]
again
yes he likes that [__] yeah we'll be on
the wrong Channel today I feel uh though
yeah I don't like that this is just not
it
not it this is just not Norway
yeah
I'm infinitely smarter than you and um
infinitely more successful than you hey
anybody asking to be a mod is going to
be banned I just want to let you guys
know stop it [__] you
okay uh so that's that on that
[Music]
uh
yeah do we switch sure
I don't know I'm not sure hey we enjoyed
the suit
I wish somebody would roast him better
okay because that guy's such a [__]
weirdo yeah he's got this Gumby ass
looking dude what are his comments like
good question are people like here
people eating that [__] up or what's up
I think I've seen his videos a few times
in my four years so I'm assuming he's
has somewhat popular Canadian Chinese
boy has dropped by okay I don't like the
way he says boy it's boy giving bad
vibes giving me a boy
problem okay drop by for what I ain't
even gonna lie this one kind of funny
but one with the boys gotta go so
embarrassing
you pay for the experience
uh
yeah I guess so people
yeah people need to roast him harder
though this is
really bizarre
I was being Reckless or some what Gumby
needs to be in a Max security prison for
sex offenders box me [__]
the only suit that Gumby ass looking
dude should be suited up in is a goddamn
orange jumpsuit
I'm trying I'm trying I'm trying to uh
trying to bring it back to him you know
what I mean or do people thirst for him
somebody in the comment says can you
gift wrap me
yeah Daddy
interesting
yeah
careful with that one
she blew my eardrums out
people are on to him
okay let's switch all right
[Applause]
okay here we go
I was having too much fun I heard you
were just oh so let's see here
who do we got
oh is Zach's not gonna be here
yes I can cover you then
how's everyone doing how's everyone
feeling
silence
nothing NADA I'm doing pretty good I'm
doing great thanks for asking all right
good I'm having a great time here I want
to hear some more chatter
all right
um so I prepared something else
um
okay I'm gonna talk about that okay
thank you
segments called bricked up
it's called bricked up where where we
talk about Legos
um
I just want to see what's going on in
the new what's up and then Lego website
you know it is a crazy long penis
who's let me play with my
yeah cam can you knock it off what's
that music oh I'm sorry oh am I not
muted I just want to see what's going on
I don't do that like a website I don't
[__] do that sorry about that no
you're done why would you do that wait
what he's wait what uh
I built this new uh Endor set it was a
good build
um
this was a fun build for all you Lego
aficionados out there
um is it too loud do I need to turn it
down it's a little loud so hold on
hey can you guys fact check uh uh ask
chat GPT what's the most desirable set
right now I think it's the new uh the
old fighter pilot we have a show to dope
look at the back jacket look at the dog
excuse me don't talk back it's in the
dog eat them
the uh fighter pilot helmet is retired
um
I really want this what are these going
for can you get ass chat GPT
Ethan we've done enough chat gbt for
today
uh the most desirable Lego set is the
Lego Star Wars ultimate collector series
Millennium Falcon that's the most
desirable one according to chat GPT
okay can you ask it about no we've done
enough let's move on
okay
no more chat gbt okay
um
anyone see the Rivendell set
that one's pretty cool too let's move on
I'm trying to let's move on
um rivendell's pretty cool I know
there's a lot of people who do this
house for no reason I want it
and um I really like Rivendell
a big Lord of the Rings guy oh me too I
love the Lord of the Rings yeah it's
[__] great would you build this set I
mean I know you got your gangnams and
I'm Dan right now yeah I know oh Dan do
you put cam dude I'm the one that builds
uh Gundams yeah right or Warhammer Dan
oh yeah I paint Warhammer 40 hammer or
do you is it 40K or just regular
Warhammer
you should you should know this uh
regular Warhammer okay well it works I'm
not scared of that
uh things I've built
um I just built this new uh Lego Disney
Castle it's on my set
sorry to hit you off really proud of it
oh that's pretty good yeah I bet the
little boys you have love that you guys
little boys they're two little Sons okay
that's for little kids right sure yes
for babies yes for for babies
um now what I want from Lego is uh I
really want a C3PO helmet I think that
could be cool again this is not inclined
officially uh license merch but um
can you ask chat EBT if they're ever
gonna make a C-3PO helmet we've done
enough of this
okay who's the [__] boss here
sorry oh we got a meme
don't be sorry you're Dan cam oh I'm not
you got you got to feel [__] you hey
chat [__] you chat I'm Dan how many
elves can you [__] take
uh spicy meme we got from cam
[Music]
um and that's pretty much the segment
did you show the meme that I made I did
I did show it I don't think we saw it on
screen okay
I never fight for it come on it's a
picture of you
that Bubba
getting us claimed uh chat GPT says yes
Lego has produced several sets featuring
C3PO the Beloved protocol Droid from the
Star Wars franchise that's not what I
asked
Ethan that's what you asked I'm sorry
dude
is this what it's like you still haven't
shown my music I [__] showed it cam
[Applause]
um
[Music]
this is Havoc man
ah let's see what else we got
[Laughter]
all right well we should wrap it up
we're going on two hours here yeah no no
no no
even though he's having too much fun
back there he's having too much [__]
fun back there
I don't know how long it's been uh all
right uh we'll do something quick uh how
about that
um I linked their website
great
I am a Muslim this is the ego I am black
I am gay no it says it says Lego with
ego I'm gay I am gay I am gay
[Applause]
no Overkill there bud
lego my eggo this is ego
the [__] you send me waffle website for
hello I don't think we've seen my meme
[Laughter]
I just in case you missed it I sent one
cam I showed it about five [__] times
I don't think it got caught on the
screen
what the [__]
there's the [__] meme it's beautiful
great work
it's you
you see uh there's a guitar but your
head is a Lego brick yeah it's real real
original
I liked it
um so yeah that's my presentation I'd
rather have sex with Trader Shredder
you know I usually don't play those for
a reason
I sent the right wing
Jew
uh-huh little [__] shot
customized load Lincoln Logs what is
this
wow congratulations you're fat I love
playing with winky bars when I was a kid
I bet you like playing with yourself too
cam
Ethan Ethan you're going too far with
that let's calm it down
oh
all right well that's it that's the
episode Go Home Folks wait
that's it like you're also a [__] person
thank you
you're a fat fat fatty thank you
appreciate it keep eating fatty dude
Dan step in well you're fat all right I
gotta pull this on the rails all right
thanks everybody for watching uh we'll
be back next week we got a big guest
coming up fat ugly and stupid
look here's the deal I'll just give you
a big fat kiss
are we done we rotating
all right that's it well well done Zach
well done
Give It Up
I love the name of it
great great name
oh my God what the [__] it smells so
good here
you got a candle and then the fan blows
it in your face that's so gone dude and
the lighting here is so nice too
you have a what
you have a blood pressure monitor why
oh my God I feel like that would raise
your blood pressure always seeing your
blood pressure all right guys
enough with the crosstalk yeah also
I'm
hot I'm too hot
I'm I'm too hot
somebody could I got it I got it I got
it thank you everyone get the air thank
you
[Applause]
before you do anything I'm actually a
little cold
I'm actually I'm actually cold
[Applause]
good help
that's all I'm saying
all right what do we got here what we
got in the dock
um
jeez does anyone want boba
always I would love Boba you're speaking
my language
thank you Sam how do you order this
stuff is it just do you have plugged in
on the browser can I order I've never
wanted something more in my entire life
than I want Bobo right now hey guys can
you send your Boba order and Discord get
me something that doesn't taste like
fish
no fish
the puffer fish right the one this thing
turns into a circle
yes it's on
all right uh let's see here uh Dianne
Feinstein
um
one old hag right am I right that's not
fair I wanted to do that one it's so
funny okay I'm Sam though
um so Dianne Feinstein
is the senator from Utah
um she has been in office since
and she's
189 years old how old is this guy again
like 30 unbelievable it's unbelievable
and she still hasn't retired so anyways
uh she's been out with um
with chickenpox for the last 12 months
she's been gone for 12 months now
[Music]
I just had to button Dan
that Dan
I got a little in character you got a
little carried away there buddy
how do I recline the cities what am I
you're supposed to be keeping me on the
rails
the the remote you guys the remote
voters and Discord please I didn't get
everyone's order
I want a non-fish non-fish you got that
one I'll try my best but real quick what
that means chocolate mocha what does
that means
you're cold I'm cold okay I'll get that
um so I'm sorry uh Diane Feinstein she's
the center from California apparently
not Utah
[Music]
um and I see she was the member of the
democratic party apparently oh come on I
know she's a senator for California okay
can somebody uh just Factor Ethan is
correct somebody mute
um Sam's Mike thank you
um so anyways uh
she's missed 91 votes in the last couple
months 91.
and she arrived back at the hill today
and I gotta say she looks great
she looks real healthy real happy
she looks ready
to legislate man you know no one's ever
looked better
no one's ever looked how I can't how do
I
I don't understand I don't understand
this computer
look at that it works look I just I just
do this and it goes it goes right by I'm
trying what the freak what is going on
yeah you're not you're not a streamer
YouTuber this is so ridiculous
foreign
so anyways yeah she looks she looks
fantastic she looks gorgeous
slay Queen would anybody
I think she looks slave
yeah would you girl bossing slay Queen I
mean back in the day maybe you know
would I can we ask can we pull the check
is it wood or wooden can we asked to
chat that would or wouldn't
how do you want to word it
uh cam can you make sure to send your
bubble order
yeah I just I just sent you guys a phone
okay the poll is here's the poll here's
the poll
would you if you had the chance not say
no to the opportunity to sleep with
Dianne Feinstein yes or no wait can you
say that up one more time would you if
you had the chance not say no to the
chance to sleep with Dianne Feinstein
yes or no
I think that's that's a great pull
that's right gbt didn't have an answer
for that I think you can just put would
you
it's too late I already asked okay
do what love said all right you got to
take that pull down that's a bad boy
that's a bad pull you got to get rid of
that poll I wrote it exactly how you
told me to write it it's a bad poll Dan
no it is for about too long listen to
love baby did you send your bubble order
oh
kind of I got I got kind of confused
look the chat's calling it a bad poll
they're right they're right what so what
do you wanted to actually say on a
serious note guys does everyone want
hamburgers
Oh wrong and then Dan you want a veggie
burger
am I answering in character no no no
this is a real question uh yeah sure if
you're and then everybody else wants a
hamburger from where veg two veggie
burgers
okay okay
I tried Boba I gotta be honest I'm just
talking this is just all right we're
we're breaking the we're breaking the
illusion right now the Bobo ordering
just was way over my head too many
questions the ice the Boba the drinks I
mean I was like wow so we're just gonna
do burgers and stuff Burgers from where
uh
uh nearby that you like I mean obviously
don't say it
but there's there's a ton of options you
know
can we get some uh maybe some you know
bed music is that
yes some elevator music
where is that sorry I actually where's
that at uh
it's uh
sure
that's pretty good
I'll just pick a place
you guys like Five Guys Shake Shack
Five Guys is good you like five guys
I'll take a lettuce wrap yeah
is Five Guys good I don't know
I feel they're over hyped a little bit
you good bro
all right and and back okay
I don't know what do you guys think I
mean like listen I it maybe it's ageist
or whatever but I just think that
everybody over the age of 75 should be
turned into Soylent Green and turned
into food for the population
and I mean honestly
here let me type it
watch it let me just tell me if this is
okay to say
watch it
watch your profanity
okay that is definitely do not say that
Jesus I really do not say that are you
nuts I say that do not say that are you
nuts I think you should say it thank you
uh no whoever you are I think it's fine
what's the big deal what role are you
right now I'm Zach oh thank you Zach
thank you Zach
all right
all right I'm not gonna say it if Zach's
the only one saying to say it then I'm
not gonna say
but you know what say I want a vacation
I'm not gonna do that real quick
I'm hot
I got it I prefer if you could I'm
really hot right now I got it I I like
it's like a thousand degrees in here
right now if I speak I am in big
so
so yeah she's back and you know I was
reading that like they couldn't confirm
judges because uh
because she wasn't there
um and like I said what is
what are these [__]
Psychopaths
do it on in DC I mean
this woman she's got she doesn't just
have one foot in the ground July
[Music]
and Feinstein is an old hag she can't
govern anymore she's almost dead that's
America
cut it off
thank you
that's America
that's America to me
all right that's enough cut it off
so apparently it's been an Open Secret
that her mind is just it's just
applesauce and has been for years and I
don't know I don't know
what do you think I mean damn like what
what can we do about people like Dianne
Feinstein what what kind of action can
we take
um just you know freaking
I got nothing
I've got nothing I've lost the role you
know uh back home in a Dearborn keep it
together Dianne Feinstein came in uh she
like toured the town you know like my
cousin Tim was there
um
my cousin Tim was there yeah wait Dianne
Feinstein she's from California why was
she in Dearborn uh I I guess Tim matched
with their own Tinder or something like
that and I guess he you know cousin Tim
did yeah he had to hit his at his way
is this true
dude how many elves can you [__] take
I don't know I don't know
so anyways I mean I guess that's it it's
just
I don't know what we're gonna do I'm so
black pilled on this one guys I gotta be
honest I gotta be honest
you guys see I dropped my meme in
oh there's a meme hold on that's a good
one let's take a look
okay here's a meme from cam
I mean
it's true isn't it it's a little true
isn't it thank you well that's a little
bit controversial
oh boy should I button this I don't know
I don't know
I mean it's funny it's funny
it's funny at the end of the day yeah
it's you know what are you gonna do what
are you gonna do I do like
well
I love it oh here's some information
from a b uh the national flag of the
United States of America consists of 13
equal this is just information about
what the flag is
why did you send this baby
why did you send this uh you think I
don't know what the flag is
real quick
it's scorching hot in here I got it I am
sweating sweat dribbling down my ass
crack right now okay
um
Dan can you send your Boba order
I thought we weren't doing Bobo
I thought we were doing Burgers
Mercury's in retrograde
right yeah
here here's here's what Amy just sent me
American flags
oh
Maybe
look at me
I'm gonna [__] you up later look you
know I'd love a vacation so you know
all right let's move on this is a
disaster
this is an absolute disaster what is
this love sent me something
now this this is great love thank you
yeah
[Music]
all the way up to 70.95
mute it
wow you yeah yeah
you should just do everyone's job
baby would never send me a video this
good look at this Michigan I'm see
that's where you're from maybe you don't
even send me this yeah my cousin Tim you
know that's actually like his load
stands all over that flag you know [__]
you baby
I know a lot about cousin Tim I gotta
tell you a lot more than I ever thought
I would oh of it
yeah you're muted
Ian speak up
I love how every station has become
about me somehow
[Laughter]
uh why did you send this baby Michigan
is the best state and here's why
okay did Lena send her Boba or is she
gonna be here Lenny
[__]
Lenny
is Lena not here where's Lena oh is she
out walking the dogs oh I know the dog's
over here
when he gets back so I can order she's
vlogging you've got this [__] locked
down
look at this guy oh look at this
precious little bit huge
look at this baby angel yes Alfredo's
gonna rip on me next oh my God
well he's such a sweet little baby angel
baby little puppy baby did Alfredo send
his bubble order
yeah yeah we'll get you some Brooklyn
whatever you want your little prince
you're the best you're a little angel
you know uh my cousin Tim uh knows
alfredo
uh yeah you're a little tight here
here's a meme uh cam just sent let's
take a look
somebody could get that to uh cousin Tim
just let him know I love that
I heard the Godfather music don't don't
get me started please don't get me
started on that
it'd be
once again
you bring up this cousin Tim I thought
who's this cousin Tim
you broke my heart I don't know any
cousin
he's not relevant to the show I mean
people don't know his cousin Timmy this
is the company card
it's the company card on this one mute
your mic the mic is open
the numbers
I don't remember I don't want to
actually put it on your
on your card if gears is in here yeah
all right I'm running I don't know how
else to be Ethan I've run out of bits
here we could probably move on they're
really
there's nothing else to say about Dianne
Feinstein she's all she's an old [__]
she's an old [__] [__]
shut up [__]
I mean I know I I don't like to use that
word but
shut up [__]
shut up [__] thank you thank you Zach
all right can I can I tap out can we
rotate are we ready I'm just placing
order on our Burger okay right now we'll
give it one more second done
what does the chat think about uh Dianne
Feinstein what do you what do you guys
think
I'm done by the way oh okay let's go
yeah it's done all right we're rotating
thank you so much thank you for being
here about your PIN Sam you got all that
it says it'll be here in like 20 minutes
it's fast all right Olivia you're up I'm
Gonna Come
okay I'm gonna come from everywhere
hello hello
okay so we just did Diane
oh [__] the [__] is it Michael
okay
so I see do we want to do good doctor
scene going viral
I think as the host I'm going to decide
that we're going to do the good doctor
scene going that is a sleigh thank you I
totally support you that is a sleigh
thank you guys thank you okay so
this is the clip-in question and your
your camera is really like not even
anywhere on this [__] hold on I gotta
talk about how Ian has this formatted
every person on the crew has their so
this is one two three four five
six wait what no no seven
press F1 through four yeah one two three
one two three four yeah okay
uh that's the four main and then I'm F9
why do you why you like you're so
unwilling to participate your ass is all
the way at F9 well because F five
through eight is the camera your screen
when people react to it
those are like the most commonly used
ones Olivia's oh love is oh okay yeah
cam is H I think okay wait
okay so this is right Olivia's up now
yeah okay Queen okay Queen
um so this is the clip in question
hello oh [__] how do I show the
F5
wait a minute my cousin Tim
hi cousin Tim who made that Meme so cute
of them
okay such a sleigh ready
[Music]
do I have to do this yes
I am a surgeon I am a surgeon I am I am
a surgeon I have a surgeon Dr Hunt I am
a surgeon doesn't take a rocket surgeon
Ethan
okay so how do we feel on the initial
view of that clip that Dr Han is a
sleigh he went out with
the girl from E News he did Olivia
you know everything it's a slave you are
so smart and so beautiful yeah is this
thing did it did you guys hear that uh
the Kanye West is apparently coming out
with some new music
oh wow Ian how do you feel about it now
what well I'm pretty excited as a huge
fan I think the world of Kanye
frankly he's never done wrong in my eyes
even today
even today yeah to this day you support
that's really interesting you're a very
dedicated fan really yeah even today I'm
not a fake fan I I ride with them for
that yeah you are bullying me
you are bullying me I did not like it
wait what okay
real quick uh chat GPT says that a
surgeon is a medical doctor who
specializes in performing surgical
procedures to treat various medical
conditions
a b
um
so the good doctor featuring uh Freddie
highmore's Dr Sean Murphy and Daniel Day
Kim Dr Jackson Han clip what the doctor
feet oh the good doctor featuring
Freddie highmore's Dr Sean Murphy and
Daniel days Kim doctor Jackson Han clip
is going viral on Twitter and meme edits
are pouring out let's see some more
Clips yes thank you
yes thanks Olivia you're the best
there's the clip go look for the clip
no no what do you see
can't do this
don't no no no no no no no no
Dr Murphy bad surgeon Dr Murphy
Dr Lim keep her stable from what I
understand this character has autism but
the the actor does not
correct interesting interesting
uh yes people with Autism can become
surgeons just like anyone else
thank you a B I didn't ask
I mean just do my job yeah it's true
it's true thank you but you can shut up
do my job
how do I there we are
Maybe
[Music]
a b
oulders yeah let's move on all right
next
piece of [__]
oh my God should we get boba
oh my God girl you are just a broken
record today
you know maybe tomorrow girl Hello
Olivia
James they need to know if they don't
you really suck at lying I know too bad
it's an important social skill
so how do you know when to lie
when people need to know things uh don't
don't try this one they don't don't
why it's a lie okay I can't fight I
can't find Zach oh [__]
okay I think you can show it it's okay
wait don't lie you can show it lie
through okay and feel good about it what
if they need to know the truth why are
we not showing it it got oh then let's
watch oh it got claimed
the [__] what though
what about if you make play it just the
audio just play the audio that's all we
need are you sure yeah okay
surgeon if I get the show banned while
I'm hosting no no just play the audio
you're good okay
[Music]
someone can handle it
some can't so how do you know who can
and who can't I've essentially been
banned truth if they like you after then
you'll know
if they don't then it doesn't really
matter anyway
you have cancer
you really suck at lying I know too bad
it's an important special skill
so how do you know when to lie
when people need to know things they
need to know if they don't lie through
your teeth and feel good about it what
if you feel good about it truth but
it'll hurt them
yes okay beautiful
butthole some can't so how all right
Olivia I've heard enough out of you
today the truth just uh a little bit of
extra information uh yes yes children
can get cancer although it's relatively
rare compared to adults
actually I saw the movie My Sister's
Keeper when I was 10 and I stayed for 10
minutes then had therapy for at least
two years after that because I was so
scared
um just a little fun fact for you from
The Host
my parents uh yeah made me go to therapy
I'd to write cancer in a bottle and
throw it in the ocean I'm literally not
kidding she was about two a particularly
provocative little monster of about the
same age was standing above her on the
same bar she was gripping okay so this
one didn't get claimed
my chromosomes it's like Jared and me
not XX boy I'm a girl you're transgender
yes no Quinn has wait uh check the score
how
oh man
what's happening can we not actually not
watch any of these
am I able to watch it or no no no just
there's a meme in the Discord oh okay
okay yeah no no no this wasn't like an
emergency can you open that is an
emergency it is you should look at this
man yeah
yeah that is good [__] watch it
who's over there
oh do you made that Amy yeah okay
I'll get on that's a sleigh it's a
sleigh
oh wait I gotta do something okay wait
here you go no you're good
are you how are we doing how are we
doing you figuring out how to pull up
the meme there
no who's the Boomer now
wait I thought you didn't show anything
you're good oh okay I think it's fine
yeah I'll die
I will uh that's a really good meme
thank you so much Cam
hey no problem yeah
and
don't show the screen don't show the
screen don't show the screen how do you
do this every day okay
some additional info real quick a meme
is a cultural element or behavior that's
transmitted from person to person
through imitation or replication
thank you a b a fact
moving on
me not XX like you science says he's
male no Queen has gender
it's not the one she identifies with
she's mismatched Dr Murphy but
biologically hi girl hey girl I see you
thank you
miss you
that's logically that's it
that is how Ethan and Ian act okay deep
tenderness that mcburney's point could
be acute appendicitis Murphy get Imaging
to confirm what does this guy have
[__] AIDS or some [__]
do you wear dresses
is a boy who thinks he's a girl I want
to know why he thinks that sometimes I
have dresses but sometimes I wear
leggings do you like the color pink I'm
more of a purple girl do you play with
dolls I'm more of a purple girl
let's go
yo I gotta say I like the representation
but this dude he's not ready to be a
doctor
wow you really popped off yeah
you're like really passionate about it
you know I love uh the representation
and all that but this dude is just
after the whole Selena non uh Ian has
gone full
Joker with topics wait hold on Zach
where are you do this
G or k or something oh oh g r k o
for Olivia Olivia since Ian went full
saline and on he's been very outspoken
no no this
okay I see it
um yes yes
okay hey just need to check in with my
girl
okay next clip let's see
I can't get it onto my screen Olivia has
found herself in hot possibly soon to be
boiling water oh my God
uh real quick um just some additional
information waving your hand generally
refers to the action of moving your hand
back and forth typically as a greeting
or gesture of farewell
thank you a b
next
good sound whoa
[Music]
very quiet Jesus
you want me to start over
you play it with sound maybe just play
the audio on this one okay
kind of graphic
what the [__] is happening
it's a goddamn visual gag you got to see
the damn video
okay let's pause really quick am I
allowed to show this video or no I don't
know what's the deal did this get
claimed or something it says not claimed
yeah go ahead you're good play it okay
dude this guy's life is such a travesty
people are just dropping dead everywhere
around him okay that's a crap
real quick um if a bunch of shattered
glass fell on your head it could cause a
range of injuries depending on the size
shape and Blossom oh my God enough
just doing my job
I'm a job
well if you do it again we're gonna have
a big problem prick
you guys come on let's move on yeah
let's move on [__] you up I hope this
doesn't make you sound like a douche
screen
no not bad
what that was the dock I'm trying to get
it on my screen
thank you
there we go
um meme edits let's go this video is
blocked we can't do that one me met it
one
time
[Music]
I am a surgeon
I'm not leaving your office
[Laughter]
some quick info it is not physically
possible for a human being to shoot
lasers from his eyes
little foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
it's possibly a surgeon
[__] loud
oh my God every time
dead air
is that air so how's it looking on the
burgers when are they getting here Sam
one sec let me look that up real quick
I don't know where where'd you order it
from I'm not gonna say the name I don't
I don't remember the name actually if
you go to orders you should see it there
it's
preparing our order it should be here
estimated 3 30 right now yeah
I'm sorry I got it I got how many did I
get yeah I got a burger for everybody oh
[__] thank you I got a burger for
everybody I got a lettuce wrap for Zach
and a veggie for Cam and Dan thank you
thank you very much thank you so much
what kind of veggie patty are we talking
here
talking impossible we talking Beyond I
like it in black bean we talk in uh soy
saitan soy what are we talking soy no
that's stupid that's stupid
that's just that um okay
get out of here
I'm not going
I don't like it yeah [__] soy soys for
baby back [__]
okay um so while we're waiting for the
burgers I can give you a little bit of a
circumstantial
uh stuff that has to do with that scene
it was taken from an episode
breakdown that's the title of it in
which Dr Murphy confronts Dr Han after
being excluded from taking part in a
major operation the episode originally
aired in 2019 but it's only just going
viral now
the plot of the episode if you if you
must know is Dr Han believe Dr Murphy's
autism could have jeopardized the
procedure but he was eventually fired in
part due to discriminating against his
colleague's disability ableist Dr Han
sorry
[Laughter]
this is crazy Ian
how do you do this
it's like you got a voice Scrambler on
it's so [__] crazy Ian there's like
uh Ian half a second delay and it makes
me
serious
yeah but uh shout out Dr Juan he's
absolutely right shout out Dr Wong it's
hard to talk over there isn't it
I mean you do this by your own you
choose to do this well I'm trying to
talk normally it's so hard it's like
impossible yeah
um the good doctor has remained one of
the biggest network shows in the U.S and
was recently renewed for a seventh
season maybe I knew you liked that fact
I was just about to say that you were
about to say that yeah yeah you just
beat me too yeah I know I know I'm just
spitting facts you know I know about it
because it comes on after the bachelor
uh Bachelorette who's Sam
uh spin-off following a young lawyer
with OCD has also been greenlit
following a successful backdoor pilot
this year
yeah I'm looking forward
to the new show about
uh a
quadriplegic uh boat captain
they're building
the disability Avengers
um
at the end of the pilot of the OCD
lawyer he's gonna be standing there in
his office
I'm building a team
oh
yeah the season finale
quadriplegic captain
shows himself into the catapult
and they shoot but they run out
[Laughter]
oh [__] it's so hard to talk to him
oh [__]
oh
um well that's the end of that story so
if we want to switch
we only got one more right we're almost
back to our starting places right oh my
goodness
oh y'all are funny
uh oh
[__] you guys got jokes I must have
misunderstood the assignment
and let me just say every single one of
you looked super cool sitting in that
chair I'm just saying y'all look great
cam what I can't hear what these
headphones is that it's the uh oh holy
[__] this is stuff uh it's the ear buds
hey
who's my ab I gotta get your old waxy
ass [__] maybe I don't want to do it
to Olivia it's everyone's earwax ass
say it okay guys I'm trying to run a
show here please
Olivia what's what's today
um Wednesday May 10th 2023. what
nothing we gotta go to break
I don't wanna can someone translate for
him what is he saying uh it's the date
today he he said the date he said it was
May 10th 2023. all right yeah we gotta
go to break what do we got here 30
minutes we gotta go break right right
I'm sorry uh we have okay let's look at
this Tick Tock Deep dive on this guy
Ethan Timon
to mean another okay so this dude is not
okay God loving Alphas uh he has some
super cringe videos we found him on
Instagram let's just
I don't know let's just start here
this is his Instagram wait
AB I thought I asked you to link his
Tick Tock you want me to link his tick
tock
it's right here it's in the dock where
it's literally I highlighted it for you
where I highlighted for you right here
it's under number four Ethan it's right
here
right here just just send it just send
it okay okay
dank you just pull it up oops
no okay here I got I got it
okay here we go
bro let's go out this weekend there's a
crazy event happening there'll be a ton
of checks let's just go have fun and let
go a little oh I know this guy ain't my
kind of fun for me my friend dated him
uh for a couple months spending time
with my Creator oh really yeah what
maybe
nothing I said nothing Jesus I desire
and more importantly becoming a better
version of he's got this really nice
place at Pico and gray so if your kind
of fun is getting [__]
that's cool what'd you say we don't do
that we're focused on God Olivia don't
don't
do it
we don't say that so what do we think
he could Loki get it yeah
yeah
uh you know
you know he looks like he'd be you know
something in the Holocaust I don't know
what but you know
you know
I shouldn't say this but
does anyone else kind of feel like
not that I just say it you know no don't
no I think he might be gay
what's your frame of reference here
God this chair [__] I mean all these
Alpha dudes this cheers
I'm still sore from sitting in it for
like five minutes this is I don't know
how the [__] do you do this for four
hours
AB can you find out how to wrap up the
show
Amy can you find out how tall this
random ass dude is yeah yeah yeah it's
almost like it's not easy
but I promise you I won't give up
I have no idea what's happening in your
life right now
but I still trust you
even though I don't know where you're
taking me
I do know
that you got me
amen
Amen brother
all right dumbass cam how you doing back
there you're making me a little nervous
how quiet you are
cam
oh
you gotta hit the switch
I'm working on something good but I I do
want to put every no offense I didn't
want to put everyone's communal waxy
[__] earbuds in so I can't really
hear you but I think I think I heard his
name and I'm working on something good
awesome
you know we're at three hours
mess with me hey Dan why don't you shut
the [__] up
shut up [__]
um hey Ethan just so you know we're at
three hours
what'd you say what
let me be clear he doesn't actually talk
to me like that I'm over exaggerating
so am I
what did you guys feel that what was
that
earthquake
does Dan do that
[Laughter]
character oh you guys killed that I felt
something
that was just Zack speaking
I'll let call Madrid's job
but most of the ones I love
Ian what do you think about Kanye
no I mean just like you know because I
know you were writing this movie about
him and everything do you think like you
still do you still like his music
yeah you know how do you feel about
Kanye you know it's just one of those
things
yeah whatever dude I'll become comma
what do you think we liking this guy
I mean yeah I got it I dropped it in
um I have a I have a fact the the hat
that he is wearing is
um New York Yankees which is a baseball
team in New York oh really
literally is he even speaking English at
this point I'm sorry
I'm sorry I sent my meme
said that the uh that the New York it
doesn't even matter Yankee it doesn't
even matter
it's okay
I mean I I I I heard you I heard you
thank you Olivia that's a funny thing
how the [__] do you say
how do you open this thing
okay so we got to uh
a jack Timone
that was his name right yeah yeah
so I found some furry
kind of hot sexy Timon
from uh Lion King no no this is this is
great actually everything you do is
great Kim everyone here
mostly oh come on
who's next
uh
uh oh I lost the dock
how it's okay you're doing great sweetie
yeah what do you mean it's right there
wait
I've only made my career off
using a computer how do I use this
online
at this point I'm not even [__]
around with the dog go
um
just go into uh you know click control h
I gotta defend Ethan this is
once you lose the dock it's gone no it's
tough
I don't need a cheerleader thank you do
you need help
no I got it
move on
we're at five hours
[Laughter]
no we're trying to make Ian's fingers
strong with all that switching just give
me a sec
dead air dead air
should we read some donors
uh it's 21st birthday today
happy birthday oh my God all right
here's one from uh it's my 21st birthday
today
happy birthday it's my 21st birthday
today happy birthday I'm starting to
think these people aren't actually 21.
they're 21.
[__] you
okay here
oh Zach where's the soundbite I'm 21.
[__] you
oh it's my 21st birthday today
another one
though we got about 50 of these happy
birthday oh my God [__] you happy
birthday
happy birthday
happy birthday from Michigan
Olivia Detroit Sean
happy birthday Dan okay let's look at
this video Cameron I want to know what
you guys think about this
I was scrolling Tick Tock late at night
and found this video
yeah you sent it to me at 4am
that was unwarranted
[Music]
Loki I'm not even alive
how am I type
am I interested in everyone
you know what I really you know what I
want to do I wanna I wanna kick Rich Lux
in the balls man
what I want to do
I want you I want you to shut the [__]
up Dan
can we hear this up we're at 11 hours
foreign
I feel like the ball kick is not
proportionate oh not at all this is kick
harder it's a great Point love I love
everything you say
thank you
I shouldn't say this
no no don't do it no no do you guys get
the feeling that they might be
don't you know don't do it is this like
a pleasure slap I felt gay
you know the button's not working right
now
you're free balling
that looks so [__] painful
so who is this looks like uh
oh
oh [__] no no no you gotta watch the
land to get it you know this crime kind
of reminds me of
um
I'm in character so I could say [__]
keep telling yourself
okay I'm gonna type it in Discord tell
me if I can say this
I just want to read another Dono
um 21st birthday today oh my God happy
birthday
another one it's my 21st birthday
oh my God another one happy birthday
from Detroit
there
all right you know what I'm just gonna
say it
up just we're having a technical issue
oh we got a technical issue can y'all
fix that or is that like a technical
issue it's a technical issue okay hold
on just a little technical issue here we
have some technical issue it sounds like
what do we do about it what are we gonna
do
[Music]
no
absolutely not
can't believe you said that word you got
it we got it it didn't show up you're
lucky
love that button baby
that was maybe your worst Ethan
it's been a long week
that's all I got man it is Wednesday man
on a on a real level I don't think you
you didn't hit both buttons did you
did you only get one oh
because you have to have both
which one did you hit
[Music]
yeah it's really inappropriate
canceled
okay I'm done
wait oh wait I want to get out of this
[__] chair
Ethan says he's been he's cooking
something up he's cooking us cooking
cooking up another meme over there or
Cam rather Cam's cooking up on me
before we go maybe you want to read some
more donations
um it is my 21st birthday today oh my
God happy
there we go uh it's my 21st birthday
today oh my God another one happy
birthday from Michigan
and uh Saudi benefactors 21st birthday
today can someone's having a drink I
need you you know I like to have seven
on my desk
oh
[Laughter]
I'm so good
oh that's [__] good that's the best
uh
[Music]
that's good stuff
um
how we doing back over there cam
you're muted you're muted
I'm trying to find it on his desktop
so I can uh
share it you can just copy paste it
on Discord
we've been going toys
copy it from where from Photoshop or
wherever you wherever you're making it
copy it hold on command C I can copy it
yeah and then just command V into
Discord wait dan why did you text me
why'd you message me not to mention the
guest on Friday what the [__] is that
don't don't
confirmed yet
oh my God it won't [__] deselect the
goddamn warm ipsum dude just don't don't
say it
not confirmed it's not Lauren
that's a banger
it doesn't make any goddamnage well I
sent a screenshot of it while we wait
have you guys seen this
this picture fine dude [__] leave me
alone oh wait sorry there you go can I
just take a screenshot bro you can do
that how this makes me think of Michael
Jackson
look I'll side with a B here you know
Michael Jackson
Dan is taking that stance
it's interesting Cannon
Michael Jackson that's interesting
I say that too Michael Jackson yeah yeah
I second that
damn
I'm getting too old [__] looks going 30
hours can we wrap it up
all right here it is oh we got it oh
finally
oh that was worth the wait
oh I predicted the future
[Laughter]
Zach Lewis that is so good cam
as you can see
we love a b and this is everything he he
does for this show give it up for a b
everyone
yes thank you thank you
yes yes
I'm getting out of this [__] chair
Twilight movies
he does like those Twilight movies
shout out because you're gonna [__]
need it all right and scene wow okay and
with that we are all back to our
starting positions Maybe please stand up
hey this is great I have a Coke here
waiting for me
where'd this come from I asked for it oh
thank you dude I was just I was just
feeling this
I gotta say that was interesting it's
not exactly what I expected I didn't
expect everyone to be impersonating each
other wasn't what I expected I think I
think Ian derailed us
when he started impersonating
I think that was it was funny though I
had fun y'all made a message I mean
derail but in a good one I mean it was
fun
this off okay
but we should be back
over there yeah should be back hello
everybody I don't know what just
happened yeah somehow
I don't know maybe this
yeah let me uh let me restart my program
my um my preview model is frozen people
are saying Frozen people are saying
Frozen Can you guys hear it
you're back yeah yeah
oh okay yeah it's just the delay we were
back the whole time I'm pretty sure
uh that was
awesome new one I'm glad that happened
at the end of the segment yeah in the
middle
very good you guys uh what a fun time we
had huh
so much fun and actually so many Goofs
too that we um covered in our journey
the suit guy who can forget him
who could forget DJ khaled's breakfast
phenomenal did we oh we didn't watch
how to operate a hot air balloon we did
not did anyone have any newfound respect
for our uh
for our fellow uh peers I don't know how
Dan sits in that [__] chair dude
that's starting my stuff
stay on Ethan
the thing that struck me about Dan's
situation is how close all the monitors
are to him it's horrific yeah it is it's
horrible not that uncomfortable is it
we can get you out of there buddy yeah
it feels like those monitors are like
yelling at me the entire time let's get
you up I mean I I'm used to it at this
point at least to some extent it says
only Dan is Frozen now I'm seeing it
yeah
um I will say also Ian surprisingly
um
it's incredible uh
there's a lot of buttons back there
you're starting to understand why he
doesn't interact that much on the show
well and also the goddamn Speech Jammer
headphones is like actually he's gotten
really good at it because I mean he does
chime in at times and like I I can't do
it at all because bro it's wild it's
it's about a half second behind because
of the latency in the program and you
know he's monitoring what's going out to
stream so that is important to be
listening to
um but yeah when you're trying to uh
interact
uh
with the rest of them but what's
impressive is you've got all the cams
and then you've got the picture and
picture cams
so right Ian's doing a lot of work back
there it's a lot thank you Zach is
pushing a lot of work back there
the sound bites I I don't know how you
do it I was just typing in keywords you
were going ham dude yeah I don't think I
stopped one for one second
and um
let's be honest what a b does is very
I don't know I was just goofing around
very really being looking everything up
like that was more a parody of you
asking for everything to be looked up on
chat BBT than anything a B's doing yeah
maybe I'm I'm sorry if I went a little
too far I'm not offended thank you guys
wait what did Zach I was just I was just
trying to live in his skin a lot of the
times I couldn't really tell what was
going on in the show when I was over at
cams and Zach do you not have a preview
screen back there I do it's Frozen right
now though okay because I couldn't see
the show when I was yeah it froze for
some reason
yeah
maybe you're the best you are amazing at
your job thank you thank you yeah I hope
extremely hard working thank you and so
good uh thank you AB is like Atlas he
carries he carries the world on his
shoulder baby's camera is still frozen
by the way so Ian's just cutting to him
looking very uh stone-faced carrying
forward so so can is anything working
yeah yeah it's so I restarted my the
setup that we have is uh
so we have so many cameras that some of
them come to my computer and some come
to Ian's and the ones that are plugged
into my computer all froze so I
restarted the program they're slowly
coming back online I should be back
momentarily yes so uh but in general um
it was fun everyone did great
it's a great time
lots of roasting we got boygas
oh these dogs you guys
I know I'm sorry they used to get
hamburgers but Shredder you can't get
the hamburgers in here no hamburgers I'm
so sorry
sucks
[Music]
so but yeah the hot the hot air balloon
video
this is one of the ones that people
someone texted me
they're like hey your day is going bad
but hopefully this video cheers you up
and it did actually it was very good
here's the video they sent me
it's awesome it's [__] awesome
is there no audio
yes you can see the audio
as you can see there's some kind of
idyllic Park setting oh thank you Sam I
got I got French fries for everybody I
thought we were all share but
thank you oh my God this is
no I'm good
oh my God
I got it for everyone to share
[Music]
type one
yeah of course thank you
so
[Music]
idyllic Park Utopia
here comes a dude on high air balloon
perfectly grazes the ground
just to [__] annihilate
everyone and everything my favorite part
is when you get a glimpse another dude
in the basket he's just panicking
fighting for his life look at this [__]
look at this guy in the yellow shirt you
can see him just got up he's just
[__] up dude get it
look at this [__] guy here
[Music]
I think I might try to jump out
you know that was him [__]
hmm
oh my God
this is insane
[Music]
um everyone's getting their food right
now
taking a little moment
[Music]
yes
here's a video so we got this submission
from I know I'm sorry Shredder
we got this really interesting
submission
from a guy who wants to go on a road
trip with c-man
okay
tell me what y'all think about this
yo H3 podcast
we out here
I am ready to go on a road trip with
Seaman
you know see maybe you know he'll rake
my feet while I drive you'll see if you
know if it's up to his they're pretty
tan I know he likes that to 10 feet oh I
gotta look at that switch look see if
you like this look bow switched it
I'm telling you he's gonna love that
then we got to make this happen road
trip to California armless man driving
Seaman let's go so I'm genuinely curious
if this is up C man's alley we try to
get a rating from him but we haven't
heard back yet
but what do you guys think you think
this is something he'd be into
you know you never know a c-man but I am
curious to hear his response right you
never know yeah
could be a cool kind of like
kind of like a movie
yeah
Harry and mod or
it's called I watched that in a film
class
uh someone in harolded mod right Harold
and mod yeah
is that movie overhyped
I actually really liked it
was that kid a minor who [__] the old
lady
I actually don't know if he's a minor
but she is old and he is Young
I've never heard that are you never it's
about some weird [__] 70s
dysfunctional kid and I was in love with
some old ass lady he like idolizes death
and like doesn't want to live anymore
and she is getting older but she loves
life
it's beautiful I think it's weird though
let's see
and that's what you think this collected
me
here they are
this kid is like 15 years old
and he's [__] uh
I don't know Mrs Doubtfire but not
okay
Ruth Ginsburg it says Ruth Gordon
I just want to eat this food someone
said put info bran in the back in the
back seat oh my God
oh that's a dream
um I want to touch on a few things here
Dianne Feinstein man
is she 89 right now that can't be
she's 80 [__] nine years old
[Music]
and she's in charge of like
one of two is she a senator
this is one of our two senators in the
great state of California
Amy can you pull up that clip of her
there was that some hearing and she said
ask the same question twice in a row
like five minutes apart
yeah I'm sorry who is this the the
actress Dianne Feinstein Diane
it's all Frozen yeah
it's kind of hard because my screen is
frozen yeah
yeah we're off the rails here guys
I'm just focused on these
can you find that clip down
a fine sign asking the same question
twice like five minutes apart
just me
wow your show really fell off
now that we're back to our normal seats
everything fell apart I just don't fell
the [__] off
um I'm seeing that uh Dearborn has the
highest population of Arabs in the
United States
yeah I didn't ask that I just want to
throw that out there I'm looking though
didn't ask fun facts and Hometown
represent a b loose cousin Tim think I
did actually find it though
oh ab's camera's finally back
I'm back baby
here's our grates one of two senators
this is from
this isn't this is from like even a
couple years ago
there she is tweeted and I quote I won
this election by a lot end quote
obviously that's not true do you believe
that label goes far enough to prevent
the tweets harms when the Tweet is still
visible and not accurate
um
let me give you a specific on November 7
president Trump tweeted this I won this
election by a lot does that label do
enough to prevent the tweets harms when
the Tweet is still visible and is not
accurate
on November 7 president Trump tweeted
and I quote
this is
like and again
go to old age and Grace out you know
live your life but
[__] you do not run again leave me the
[__] alone she's not she she announced
when she announced that she was going
out for shingles or whatever
um that and I can't you won't be running
for reelection next year
um but yeah that's uh I'm so sick of
these old [__] that won't stand aside
it's a disgusting you know and they have
the goals to talk about how young people
don't care or how they don't work hard
enough and I'll just like [__] your
hundred-year-old ass disgusting
step the [__] aside
and you know high-level Democrats I mean
begging her to reside please God stop
[__] running they ask her just like
Ruth Bader Ginsburg no I got a [__]
my selfish desire
to not [__] retire
is like the consequence of Ruth
Ruth Ginsburg not retiring when she
should have is
[__]
yeah we lost Rover 2060. some crazy yeah
literally 100 her fault
I don't care what her Legacy is same
with Feinstein this is your legacy I'm
over it leave [__] idiot leave
like what the [__] when did this happen
this Fiasco
2020 that was three [__] years ago
imagine where she's at now
after the chickenpox or shingles or
whatever the [__]
live your life lady retire spend some
time with your grandchildren I don't
[__] know
but like I mostly people at that age are
like looking at a window
at a retirement home telling the same
okay I don't want to be rude to the
elderly they won't remember so you can
retire better but I'm saying like think
about an 89 year old you know
and then imagine that they're running
this country they're one of two senators
of the most populous state of California
imagine that
I'm so [__] over it
God damn there needs to be an age
we need an age cap
16 is the age of consent 16.
you know and I'm I'm down to do it
pretty high 80.
that's pretty high it's very high and
she would not clear it I'll I'll even be
generous like that
I mean if you wanted my ideal of what
who's too [__] old to serve maybe
like
cut off I agree you know
stand aside let other like your ass is
gonna die in like a day what gives you
the right to even govern or tell us how
to [__] live our lives when you're
not gonna be you ain't gonna be here
it doesn't even go here so don't even go
here
you know go worry about the [__] uh
policies in the afterlife
watch it watch it watch it
you know
[__] watch people say 65 days of
retirement
so what's up
this job which is like way more
important it's like the most important
job basically our whole [__]
government is some Jerry geriatric
[__] dude
a geratocracy
you know and don't let these people say
[__] about young people being this and
that [__] you
[__] you [__] you
[__] you
doesn't work for me either
[Music]
these people are enemies of the state I
don't know what else to say it
the damage that Ruth Ginsburg did is on
[__] imaginable and then you got this
old ass
Dianne Feinstein who she's on a ju she's
on a Judiciary Committee that approves
judges
and her dumb sick old ass
because her ass isn't there to vote
is 100 stopped
where the Republicans when they're doing
this they they put in like a thousand of
the most psychotic [__] anti-abortion
freak judges
that you can imagine they're sitting on
every seat in the country
now when we get an opportunity to do it
this old hag
is rotting in the hospital because she
doesn't have enough humility to retire
or anyone in her [__] life to say
it's time to stand down
[__] that dude I'm sorry Shredder
sees you getting worked up
old people they will not move aside they
hold on to power they hold on to jobs
I'm sick of it man
and that is the way that the cookie
crumbles yes sir
[__] that
don't even get me started on so I've
been trying to uh fix this issue so that
you can see the camera feed this whole
time
and I don't think it's gonna get fixed
without uh rebooting so how long we've
been going we've been going for
a little shy of three hours
and poor love is completely in the dark
because that's the same feedback so love
is just listening to us right now he
can't see it I'm just listen to him I
can't see [__] but I can't see anything
either a little weird I guess we can
just call it I'm just a ghost now we
didn't talk about Trump being found
guilty of uh
sexual abuse and defamation that was
epic
good for leftovers no there's no
leftovers just wait
you went to the UK oh my God no no is he
a royalist monarchist right Ole London
can't do this
[Applause]
God Save the King
pull out
it is ironic that Hassan who says he's a
socialist is going to support the empire
Trump let's see
Tuesday judgment came down of six men
three women
and they found former president Trump
liable
for sexually abusing and defaming
Gene Carroll
bro he's been accused by 26 women is
there at least political [__] that's
crazy
I if he wasn't present I think he'd be
in jail like Weinstein
I think he would have been like straight
to jail
so it's pretty interesting though
um her claims were past the
statute of limitation because it
happened like 20 years ago
but uh New York Pastor law specifically
saying
that for certain sexual crimes they're
removing the statue of limitation
so when they passed that law
this woman filed her lawsuit a civil
lawsuit
I heard her describing as quite it's
quite disgusting
uh three decades ago they were at a
department store they coincidentally ran
into each other she I guess is a famous
advice column columnist in New York so
he recognized her
and he said hey come shopping with me
and so
he was helping him
find a gift for a girl or something
and
she said she was having a lot of fun
with them they were
on having a good energy they were having
good banter they were
having a good time
and then Trump starts looking at like a
lingerie and stuff and he starts being
like Oh you try it on let's see how it
looks whatever
and she was like no you try it on it was
just a silly goofiness
so I guess they go and they go up
to the next floor
and at the counter there it's empty
and then she says that he like I don't
know if I can't remember if it was in
the dressing room or if it was just out
in like an empty hallway our dressing
room
okay
so they were going to the dressing room
I guess she said she thought he was
going to try it on
or they were just being silly I don't
know but when they're in the dressing
room
he pinned her against the wall with his
shoulders
this is a trigger warning
and then pull yeah yeah and then
basically R worded her I mean without
getting into the details
he pulled her pants down he took his
dick out
and then he walked off
and the thing that actually got him
because how do you prove Beyond uh
I don't know what's the way to say it
but in civil court you don't have to
prove Beyond a reasonable doubt you just
have to prove it Beyond a
more than 50 percent out
so the bar is a bit lower
but the thing that got Trump is that
when they were
doing the trial they brought in like
several other women
who said back then or any time that he
did the same thing to them
and also friends of hers that she told
right about the incident at the time
right right and then
I mean in my opinion what really [__]
him oh my God is his deposition dude
there's some clips down uh my job
this is like so bad giraffe so bad
we're still one of him I see you have
other ones here the one that blew my
mind was he was like
do you believe that uh
because rock stars are famous they can
grab one by the [__] and he says
traditionally that's been true that is
uh that's this one B historically that's
true with stars I was like what
he's straight up like kind of confessed
to doing it
this video I just started kissing them
it's like a magnet just kiss I don't
even wait and when you're a star they
let you do it you can do anything grab
them by the you could do anything that's
what you said correct well historically
that's true with stars
it's true with stars that they can grab
women but well that's what that's if you
look over the last million years I guess
that's been largely too not always a
million years how far back are we going
Donia
I know it's serious and the situation is
not funny but the fact that he it's like
a little kid like he has no sense of
scale he's like a little child millions
and millions of years dude the fact that
he even allowed himself to get so
[__] owned and deposition just proves
me that he is not smart this is insanely
dumb it's been largely too not always
but largely true
unfortunately or fortunately fortunately
he says unfortunately or fortunately
fortunately he says
we've covered all his bases he said
fortunately or unfortunately
don't say fortunately
he's like have you grab women by the
[__]
yes and I liked it
historically that's true with stars
well that's quite crazy but I think the
other clip that I have in there consider
yourself probably [__] him the most
because
a big part of his denial
um because the accusations came out and
then he said she's full of [__] and
she's making this all up and she's just
doing it to further a career or whatever
um which is what he got sued for because
the lawsuit was for defamation and so it
was it was all like his denials that he
was being sued for and specifically he
said repeatedly he couldn't have done it
because she's not his type yeah that's
that's Ironclad which like is already a
crazy thing to say but then take a look
at that other clip and how it played out
and it's he completely [__] that
entire argument anyways no no she's not
his type now let's type
she's not I prefer to rape pretty women
I mean right it's already like a psycho
thing to say but
I think you can say that yeah
Danny I'll watch it it was celebrities
there were stars a million years ago I
mean everything Laura pointed out
fortunately or unfortunately thanks I
don't need you to
um which is the top one
black and white photograph that we've
marked as djt23
and I'm going to ask you is this the
photo that you were just referring to I
think so yes and do you recall when you
first saw this photo
at some point during the process I saw
it that's
uh I guess her husband John Johnson who
was an anchor
for ABC nice guy I thought I mean I
don't know him but I thought he was
pretty good at what he did
um
I don't even know who the woman let's
say I don't know who it's Marla
Marla's his ex-wife
that's Marla yeah that's that's my wife
which one woman are you pointing each
other no here
huh
eats and the person the woman on the
right is your then wife I don't know
this was the picture I assumed that's
John is that he thought that was a
picture of his ex-wife it's not it's the
picture of the Accuser
so the whole
she's not my type thing
it's enough of your type that you
confused her for a woman that you
married
oops that's crazy isn't that one thing
you shouldn't say although to be real
even engaging with she's not my type
they even have to refute that with
anything yeah no it's insane but the
fact that he then it's already a
horrible point and then he completely
undercut it himself in deposition
anyways so
oh yeah and get this
Trump's lawyers they didn't have any
Witnesses their main defense was
cross-examining Carol that accuser
and basically
the argument
um
basically rested on why didn't you
scream
that was it nice why didn't you scream
if you were
which as you know
is a slam dunk defense
and then also he called her like a fraud
and a liar analysis so they found him
guilty of
defamation
awarded 3 million for that and then
another 2 million for
they decided that he didn't
rape her but they did decide that he did
sexually assault her
they made that distinction
and they awarded her five million
dollars
which is appealing of course or at least
claiming he's going to appeal
so I'm sure it'll get dragged out for
years more but
yeah but there's no jail time it's just
a civil case
but it is pretty um
I think
probably cathartic and vindicating for
all the women the hordes and hordes of
women who's apparently done this to
26 on record
dude that's nuts
that is nuts
Trump of course went to True social to
say I've actually no idea who this woman
is
it looks just like my ex-wife
the verdict is a disgrace a continuation
of the greatest Witch Hunt of all time
I mean again kind of
that's a Pro Gamer move man to uh
to claim that you have absolutely no
idea who this person is after you just
lost a defamation lawsuit for saying I
have no idea who this person is in the
counter it wasn't me it's all you coming
out of her house it wasn't me
approach
when me
and you know that strategy is not a bad
one for him it's worked out quite well
but me
okay because I love it his Defenders and
supporters are so desperate
to believe him oh are you kidding me was
it me
so that's [__] nuts dude
we like to troll then he's been indicted
and then rumor has it that in Georgia
they're about to charge him
for another more serious crime of uh
when he on the call when he's like yo
can you just find me like
14 000 votes or whatever yeah the
election fraud stuff
one me like sir here's a tape of you
asking for 7 000 votes
I don't know who that is it's a perfect
phone call excuse me I don't remember
being on that phone call it was a
perfect phone call
that's actually what he's been yeah he
says so perfect it's perfect perfect and
what what okay what does perfect mean
it wasn't me wasn't me
even got it on camera
who was the name
oh yeah
you guys like your burger
I'm waiting until after to
to eat you're in for a treat that was
the best veggie burger I've ever had oh
yeah okay I had really good reviews the
place yeah I'd been before it's so good
oh you have I have a bunch of fries left
does anyone want them
okay meat cheesy fries is it just cheese
that's a tiny bit of bacon oh I'm good
because
all right I'll just I'm just gonna trash
it nobody wants okay
I'm good what does it means
I saw you in the department store it
wasn't me
I heard you on the phone call wasn't me
I have a picture of you
was it me
let's see
yeah he's a giant [__] psycho piece
of [__] he would be in jail for sure
right next to Harvey Weinstein
oh yeah
also he keeps it classy he put out a
video attacking the judge
which is always a good smart thing
expect from a trump-hating clip the
judge did not bring down the verdict by
the way it was a jury appointed judge
who went out of his way to make sure
that the result
of this trial was as negative as it
could possibly be was a jury speaking to
and in control of a jury from an
anti-trump area which is probably the
worst place in the United States for me
to get a fair trial
well
my hometown yeah where I was born where
I was born and raised and lived my
entire life and people knew me and I was
a socialite and I don't have to tell you
bro that's where the crime happened
that's just kind of how it works
but just one person had to say I don't
think so I think right I mean I don't
know how it works in civil cases
but it was unanimous it could be
different depending on the state too I'm
not totally sure unanimous decision
what does it mean we'll be appealing
this decision it's a disgrace
this woman is I have them I love that no
idea who she is so Shaggy of him where
she came from this is another Escape who
is why does he keep saying it he just
lost a definite like he's gonna get sued
for it again and lose again right I
don't know who she is where she comes
from just let him cook I've never heard
of this woman to defame someone lose and
then immediately just say the same thing
that you just lost or lost yeah let him
cook I don't know her
what's your name care Caroline Carol
never heard of her me
awesome and somehow we're gonna have to
fight this stuff we cannot let our
country go into this Abyss this is
disgraceful that's a trump problem not a
my country problem
you know
one me
you have somebody running he always
sounds on the verge
he's always ready for it
but that's financed and lied about it
she totally lied about it by Democrat
operatives like just about the biggest
one there is
and she said that wasn't true they found
that she lied about it and the judge
wasn't even I guess put in as evidence
the whole thing is a scam and it's a
shame and it's a disgrace country little
[__] boy
and then please donate text Trump two
eight eight zero two two
anyway there it is okay
everything's dysfunctional here Shredder
come on you can shreddy
you can have hamburger
I'm sorry sweetheart
sorry Shred
der it's not fair it's not [__] Fair
Dad it's not fair I agree
dad I want a vape I want a bank
are you referencing the UFC thing no I
was referencing Trump that sound bite
that he just played played against that
hey Mom I want a vape
unanimous decisions typically not
required in Civil Court unlike criminal
trials where the verdict must be
unanimous civil trials typically only
require a majority so even in that case
it was unanimous
right
all right guys
uh there's no leftovers tomorrow
but we'll be back on Friday we will we
will
and that's about all I have to say about
that maybe one last because Zach you're
not gonna be here on Friday one last
plug for the road first off I want to
thank Sam again so much for the jacket
[__] awesome super cool well I'm
gonna display it behind me so it's
always here
um but yeah Roxy this Saturday a few
tickets left
um it's gonna be [__] awesome we're
all gonna be there yeah
I'll be there on Sunday
Ethan will be there Sunday yeah
we'll be there Saturday
but uh yeah I will see uh you guys
Monday
okay oh yeah well good uh have a great
show and uh thank you very well
and uh can't wait to hear about it on
Monday thank you
and uh yeah so we'll be back on Friday
so thank you guys everybody we love you
we appreciate you I hope you guys had
fun today I know we all did we had a
good time thank you wild ride huh it was
fun all right see you guys on Friday
[Music]